[Music]
hey everybody welcome uh listen uh
we're here on a very special day we've
got uh uh
what was your name again uh it's a
beetlejuice uh
beetlejuice can you say that three times
uh fast beetlejuice
oh that's two times you say one more
time come on baby i can help you out
otherwise i can't help you unless you
say three times
oh that was me i can't do it i'm not
actually at magic
and then he says showtime okay oh my god
you've been in character for the past
like 30 minutes and i'm a method actor
i'm impressed because i really was like
i thought you would have been like a
theater kid and you said you were i'm
very impressed your dedication you're
like really into this i love it
well thank you i've never seen someone
so into it as me i feel like i'm like
overshadowed i was like wow this
person's really into it
first of all happy birthday you look
amazing thank you
it's trish we're obviously we're here to
celebrate trisha's uh birthday
i make it a really big deal to everybody
it's my birthday week just so everyone
knows yeah i think it's pretty obvious
to everybody who
immediately turned it off well you said
you had similar experiences my birthday
has always sucked i have i've never had
friends like up until i was 25 i was
going to disneyland every year with my
mom it was just me my mom
and i'm like and i would cry every year
at the end of my vlogs and like i wish i
had a boyfriend i wish i had friends all
stuff like that
so now that i like started getting money
i started throwing myself parties
because i just didn't want like
depressing birthdays so
that's why i make it a big deal i think
it's
so that's why i always tell people it's
my birthday i'm making a big deal of it
because i've always had the most
depressing birthday
hey listen i've been i've been dead for
a thousand years i don't know anybody
all right so i mean do you have your mom
i mean that's pretty good where i come
from oh my god
no i could be in trouble don't get us
canceled you were doing beetlejuice like
uh mannerisms earlier
well listen people have been trying to
cancel beta juice because apparently i
was trying to [ __ ] a 13 year old girl in
the movie
listen i'll take whatever i can get you
know i'll take a corpse i'll take an old
lady and i don't even
agree because my body's rigorous you
know my cock's always hard right i feel
like you don't even know the story
though because what we were doing
when we were doing pictures hey let me
see what's behind can i take a peek or
uh what's going on with this dress
by the way beetlejuice is such a creep
well but i feel like you don't know the
story because you're taking pictures
you're like oh does he like give her
away at her wedding i was like that's
not the story
no i don't know beetlejuice i was just
watching clips i mean i watched
it once so long ago um and i have only
seen it one time when i was a kid
like he he like basically she has to
like like either is gonna kill like her
ghost in the attic that she likes or she
has to marry him like that's the
ultimate so that he can like become like
alive
like he can stay in the like real world
again but she's like 14 so everyone's
like and he's like
come on what's what i mean when you be
dead a thousand years what's
what's age right better than the not
better than beetlejuice movie pretty
equal is the broadway show beetlejuice
like i saw that on broadway it was only
on for like five months i probably saw
it 13 times on broadway and there's a
song called creepy old guy and she like
talks about how like she's creepy but he
like has to marry her and it's like this
whole child
i think that beetlejuice would be a good
husband he's kind of like a character
i don't think so he'd probably be pretty
bad i think he's a good lover
i don't think so i think he's a ghost
he's well
he probably goes he probably eats good
you know he probably goes down on a girl
like hey i'm hungry you know you've been
coming
a thousand years without a meal you know
what i'm saying i'll i'll eat anything
right
you're on wednesday i i like you're on
it today
hey babe i'm the ghost with the most you
really are embodying those characters
well what i was gonna say is that anyone
who's watched like our
our uh origin story on our
old main channel hd productions my thing
was i was always willing to go all out
for the video
and so i love doing this because it's so
fun i feel like it makes the episode so
fun
and i've i used to walk around new york
city dressed like a maniac and like um
this for me is uh this is great you love
it i love it so
interesting it's just so weird because
you're just like not the typical like
cosplayer
well not many people actually know the
real
beetlejuice you don't even know the real
beetlejuice story but you're doing good
with the voice
thank you the voice is really good i
just watched some clips and his voice
just cut somehow it just like uh
i feel like it's in my natural tenor
yeah
it's like just made for you right did
you know like beetlejuice is the title
of the film but he's actually only on
screen for 17 minutes of the whole movie
that is interesting he's not yeah
because i had an ensemble yet alec
baldwin you had moira from
now that's someone who didn't age
gracefully why he still looks good
i mean he's old but like i mean yeah you
know compared to that you know like
johnny depp is the same age and still
like whoa alec
aged more gracefully than johnny i don't
think that's true johnny looks like a
little
bit of like an emo kid like coming out
of middle school like 70.
no alec walden definitely did not age
good but oh
stop it i would [ __ ] alec before go look
at michael keaton he's 15 years older
and he's obviously you know what i'm
saying
you have played beale just once you live
forever right you can never but i could
see you as beetlejuice i could see you
like playing him in something like
theater
well you ask do do i want to be uh uncle
fester do i want to be the master no i'm
beetlejuice if somebody is casting
beetlejuice i would like to you know
let me get let me get enough chitchat
let me see what's under the dress here
come on
let me see what's under here it doesn't
it's it's fashionable not that it's
sponsored oh god
no i'm a character don't actually flash
me it's fashion of a bodysuit
i know but you went like i was like okay
oh my god
this is so weird so happy birthday thank
you this is
very exciting i really like moses
because got me like 10 flowers a bouquet
of flowers this morning it's not even my
birthday but it's like i keep saying his
birthday birthday week yeah that's what
me and hila do because one day it's like
so sad
and because i'm so depressed on my
birthday because we don't do anything we
do like the whole week oh you do too
yeah okay good i'm good or the other
person has to do all the chores and
stuff
that's really really yeah you guys don't
do chores no not
but we used to what you guys do we used
to do chores
that's cute yeah you know oh i love it
yeah
well we have a lot of festivities this
week i am so excited
we got frenemies what do you call those
tumblers
tumblers i was so excited this was per
my request yeah
actually i don't know does anyone know
why it's called tumblr maybe it's like
the old like because it can fall because
it can fall down the stairs and not
right
i don't know why it's called a tumbler
but i love these these are my favorite
cups ever
i'm so excited so today on the show we
are going to be
continuing trivia and i have just some
stuff to talk about some headlines oh
we're doing a beetlejuice reenactment
theme this is a new this is new i like
can we do that should we do it first i
mean
we might as well get out of the way
before we uh waste time no i'm so okay
i like the idea but i'm actually i'm
really bad at acting because i get so
nervous and i feel stupid it's i know
that sounds
weird the theater kid you're the mrs
song sing and dance no that's why i
never got casted i'd always like a
background actor because i really choke
up like having to like
be in front of someone take talks fine
because i'm by myself and make you know
i go in a different room that was
by myself but i have to be in front of
there's like a a crew here
it's it's ian and maybe and so now i'm
getting nervous like i can't even i
wouldn't even do this in front of like
moses i wouldn't even act so it's like
now this is like i can't
you don't want to do it you don't even
try to do it we can try but i just
but you know what's worse is like when
someone doesn't fully commit and that
person's just they're like laughing
through this thing that's why we're just
having fun come on baby but i feel like
this is like your audition and i don't
want to ruin it i feel like
it's not my audition it is because you
do have a chance you have a chance stop
it who's casting me
tim burton tim burton if you're watching
this uh beetlejuice part two i mean come
on i'm like his uh
you know his cousin who's uh a little
more pc because it is 2021 but
not quite yet wait have you seen that
tick tock trend where people are saying
like
um what tim burton uh what like
superheroes would look like if tim
burton was like directed the movies of
superheroes
no they did like spider-man superman and
then you know he casts
nicolas cage to play superman and then
it got scrapped batman
no superman nicholas cage was supposed
to play superman in a tim burton film
weirdest [ __ ] tim burnham was supposed
to do superman yeah there's like footage
there's like footage of it they were
getting ready to shoot i don't know why
they canceled it
really nicholas they did uh some test
shots with
him in the costumes so the irony of all
that is is people are like oh this is
batman up timber and directed it but
timberland did direct to batman so that
trend is stupid and tick-tock needs to
stop it because he already directed
batman with michael keaton so
well of course but people are making it
seem like he hasn't done it nicholas
cage as superman
that's not real i swear to god for a tim
burton movie yeah
i hear i have a video of it i'll play
what but why did it get canned dan
just because the studio's like they
looked at that photo yeah
really here's footage i don't know i'm
just [ __ ] right here's footage
just to prove to you that it's real what
ah look at his i'm sorry but that ain't
[ __ ] superman
oh he loves superman too that's so sad
i would have i think this probably would
have been interesting he named his son
like kyle i think
tim burton named his son kellow nicholas
cage oh nick
yeah that's a little odd nick i mean
come on well he like loves
i mean i mean come on nick i mean
there's lots of interest in the world uh
superman just a little out there
i feel like the common one people like
superman it's like in a hotel room or
something yeah what
oh there is timber in there wow i
auditioned for a 10
movie when i was 15. what happened
harley in the chocolate factory i was
too old
it would have been like a really good
veruca salt um i think i would have been
a good i got this glute
yeah that's what i thought maybe they
would do gender fluid i got a good sleep
i'm hungry mommy i'm hungry
i want chocolate that would be so cool
to fall into a chocolate river oh that'd
be the best death ever that's one of my
favorite movies ever
it's the original as charlie and talk
about characters glue i want to be in
like that i want to dress like him i
love him so i'll put the chocolate on my
face i love it you know that one scene
where the therapist where he goes uh
he's like i have a dream where i i keep
having a dream where the archangel comes
down to me and tells me where the last
uh
golden uh ticket is and the therapist
goes stop playing and tell me where the
ticket is now
oh yeah i thought that was so funny okay
that was like
they're sharing the therapist believes
his delusions can we just
um grandpa joe's a [ __ ] i know
i know that's like an old meme but the
first time i watched that i was like
this crappy joe character is a [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] like
he's crippled and then all of a sudden
when something fun happens he's like oh
[ __ ] i can walk again it's like
[ __ ] your
your 13 year old son is working his
hands through the bones and your ass
pretend to be sick in bed
yeah snl pete davidson played him on snl
and it was that that he couldn't get out
of bed and then all of a sudden he like
won a trip to the chalk factory he's
like oh it's amazing oh yeah
oh man yeah i was too old i was too old
and um also probably just not good
but my mom drove me 15 hours to uh north
carolina i was in ashland north carolina
was the audition
from illinois and we drove 15 hours and
we were like really broke and she really
believed in me
and sorry i didn't get the role well you
got the role as trisha paytas which is
the
role of a lifetime oh thank you i don't
know if it's the role of life
i love that this is tricia it's like the
trisha show
so also do should we bring out the
surprise
oh let's bring out the the surprises
really bring the surprises then we'll do
the reenactment and then we can get to
the episode
come on like i always want to surprise
with it i'm always like i feel so bad i
feel like oh
you don't have to give me anything okay
so here we go
we got the cake go ahead
we got a beetlejuice themed cake oh my
oh my god
with a picture of trisha's nutritious
[Laughter]
yeah yeah i'm afraid it's going to fall
here yeah that would be awful
here you go oh girl says happy birthday
trisha
yeah yes yes
okay and we got you a present and i
think you're really gonna love it thank
you
open that up i think it's really good
wait really
open it up and tell me where everything
gets present that i get people because i
feel like i don't get good gifts i think
this one is gonna slap but let's see is
there anything that funny like no no no
no i genuinely think it's a good present
i love all presents just fyi you could
get me like a straw and i'm like let's
just
let's see i do want some of this cake by
the way no cap
i don't even know what this is
beetlejuice would just use his hand
wouldn't he man
listen baby i haven't eaten in a minute
did we do good oh my god tell him what
it is
tell him what it it's the collector's
box from okay first of all when hip doc
came out with this
it sold out so quickly oh where did you
get this though
did you contact someone i've even
contacted them i'm like can you just
like
tell them what it is it's the my
chemical reminds my hip dot makeup
collection
and it's the collector's ball you don't
have that right no
and then it was a hot topic for me oh
this
is all right did we do it thank you
this is a home run oh my god oh my god
with the brush too
you know yeah i've seen some of these on
poshmark but i don't think they're real
this is so
exciting that's the real one happy
birthday trisha we love you
oh that's so nice hold it up show the
people
don't open it did you have to like no
it's not a problem i just want the audio
i don't care if it is i said it's not a
promo i just don't want you opening it
under the
desk oh my gosh this is
i wonder if driveway had anything to do
with this or that's just licensing
either way i love it yeah i mean if they
license it okay this is so cool
oh my gosh let me see what's inside
okay i love that you're a gerard way fan
now because you found out he
uh created umbrella academy so now you
like are like oh my god
you like flipped out i love that jaws
what the hell this guy's so talented
yeah he's so talented oh my god thank
you guys so much
this is really good i i so remember i
was on a music video when this came out
i set an alarm for when it came out and
like it's sold out it's like one of
those things where like they just sell
out in a minute i don't understand
hey when you're beetlejuice man you know
what i'm saying i'm the ghost with the
most i can make things happen
thank you you're very welcome yeah what
do i think everybody thank you everybody
thank you everybody
thank you guys
[Music]
you look the other way and i've been
taking him try some of this too oh my
god this looks so exciting wait let me
let me show
you well bring the camera what are you
waiting for
oh my gosh you knew i was gonna hit it
up
i'm tick-tocking too you really thought
i was gonna wait for candles
33 that's your number right that's my
number we're like is it are we sure
about that
you're pretty [ __ ] old dude not as
old as you
oh my gosh yeah oh thank you oh my god
the whole cruise here like i feel like
it's a party
happy birthday well we got a lot going
on today you know we got the
we're gonna do the reenactment we got
trivia i mean a lot of stuff's happening
today
when we were talking about your birthday
party or like it would just be like the
h3 people i'm like but that's like my
birthday parties too it's just people
like my hair makeup artists like people
i see throughout the years
because my birthday is coming up in june
and he was like do you want to have a
party i don't know oh it's catching on
fire oh god
yeah i know i got it i got it i got it
okay i blow it out
yeah you wanna blow it out make a wish
yeah okay
go ahead will you tell us what your wish
is
happy wait how do we do the hebrew one
how's that one go
hugs
okay oh come on you know that birthday
song bro all right let me go wish for
real okay
okay
this is so funny dude it looks so funny
as beetlejuice eating
this is so cool this is like my first
work birthday
i've never had a birthday at work
disgusting what do you mean oh my god
this is so
cool wow oh my god
okay okay i'm really impressed where you
got this for real hey
we got we got methods don't ask oh my
gosh oh my gosh
what are you crazy people you just took
your fingers thank you
oh this is so cool i think i got wax on
there sorry okay so
let's do the here let's take a pause
what's happening and let's go do our
our scene and then we'll come back and
do the pod
a tiny beetlejuice on the roof of a
building
wearing a silk dressing gown looking
like he just
dragged him himself out of bed
one of the horned [ __ ] is nude
sunbathing in the corner and beetlejuice
drapes
a blanket over her lydia's face
looms enormous in the sky
now listen before we start i just want
to say uh green wasn't really the best
uh
setting we have a green screen i'm
covered in green but okay let's do the
scene
okay here we go uh cookie they're all
dead
dead ski of course they're dead they're
ghosts
no i mean they're gone uh split
venge where'd they go the happy hunting
grounds who cares
are you a ghost too i'm the ghost with
the boat
strike that i'm the ghost with the most
babe
listen cookie i've been trapped in this
burg for hundreds of years
all i want is to get out i want to get
in
you do over here on my side
i think so well yes of course it's it's
great over here uh you'll you'll meet
all the great james dean uh sid vicious
i can't be any worse than life over here
that's right i bet they treat you like
scum don't they
um yeah oh well oh that was a great life
listen i can't help you from this side
but here's what we do
so it's simple you say my name three
times you know that that's all it is
and i'll be yours you just say my name
three times and i'll bring you over here
in style
i i don't know what your name is
okay that's a minor problem uh there are
rules i can't tell you
what my name is uh but do you know how
to play charades
yes of course you do so
uh two words right
right right right first word exact
first word okay uh first
[Laughter]
three syllables no two dummy
your fingers are so small i can't see
them
excuse me is that a baby hand joke
because uh listen i get enough [ __ ]
around here you're really gonna make
baby joke ads
in the script too oh my god okay
listen first word look behind you bibo
oh you gotta read the stage direction
moses here i'll read it
lydia looks behind her a great beetle
the size of a volkswagen
is crouching it's featherly featherly
antenna
reach out towards her menacingly
good girl exactly that's the first word
excellent you got that right
um second word be careful
oh apprehensive she jumps when a simple
a cartoon of
orange juice materializes orange juice
pours out into a glass
breakfast orange
breakfast beetle beetle
beetle fruit fruit bat
fruit battle volkswagen fruit wagon
you have a lion oh should i just go
beetlejuice
i didn't have a lion you had a lion you
were supposed to say good thing you're
beautiful
that's what that's good thing you're
beautiful kid because you're dumb
because you are dumb i don't think this
is from the movie is it it's the script
it's not
i am not beetlejuice that's it
all right your name is beetlejuice
yeah that's as bad as julio dietz listen
baby
where i compliment that much better okay
it's spelled differently but basically
you've said it twice now all i need is
one more time okay excuse me this
booming show
somebody just lift that up a little bit
thank you say it one more time
and then you'll be free you'll be free
time to improvise okay there's no scribd
say it so what do we say
say my name one more time just the
go ahead listen i can't force you i
can't say it you gotta say the name one
more time
you're supposed to go what do i do it's
showtime
it's show time i thought you did really
good
well one it wasn't the like script also
that remind
like i feel like we should have done
like the broadway version like singing
it because they say
he's like how about a game of straight
sure let's play it but he wears a second
word like
we did it you did good i mean what we
should have coulda woulda
and all you gotta do is say my name
three times three times in a row
then that would have been better but
okay that was all right sorry we [ __ ]
up your whole birthday
haven't that enough for you today that's
so me as a kid i would have i would like
there's something one thing went wrong
that's me now like one thing goes wrong
i'm like i'm over him
i loved it though it was great that was
fun i'll never i love my brother but the
story is funny he doesn't mind me
telling that honest bar mitzvah
he had a cassette of um i don't know
he had us he wanted to play um smashing
pumpkins today's the best day
you know that song today is the best day
i don't know that song for real yeah
no today is the best
thing in the band are you bashing
pumpkins
i can't wait for tomorrow what you've
never heard
and you're going to sit on me for not
knowing my chemical romance yeah they
were they were 90s
i'm sorry 90s how would you know that
means you just exposed yourself
we were all alive from the 90s
listen the point of the story is that my
brother wanted that song
and they didn't have a cd of it they
only had it on cassette and he started
crying
at his bar mitzvah on stage oh my god
what scientist is he a pisces i
literally don't even know
is that a pisces thing to do yeah to cry
on stage that's also a cancer thing to
do are you a crier have you cried i
thought
cancer was supposed to be like shell
tough chef no they're oh my god they're
so not they're really like emotional
okay well i don't cry ever okay okay
my tear ducts don't work filled with
dust that was fun do you think people
get casted out i was just gonna say i
hope
i hope some big shot director watch that
and then we'll cast us in our own
beetlejuice movie so i was actually
i'll share this story remember last week
i told you i was gonna do like a tv show
and i was like kind of excited i was
like this tv show wants me and the role
was like
they reached out to me specifically i
didn't have to audition and it was for a
plus size influencer and i was like well
oh who else is gonna like i'm the
plus-size influencer
the fatty and so i had to do a self tape
after i left last time after the podcast
i was like ah [ __ ] like i've
i told you i get nervous like i cannot
put myself on tape like that sort of
thing will just so happen
and um never heard back from them didn't
get the part well it takes time
so friday so oh they skipped over you
yeah and they never responded
what was it for can you say out of spite
i'll say it i'm just spiteful but yeah
yeah you're bored like oh no you love
that show
they reached out and they're like trisha
payton is checking for your availability
on april 30th for a plus size influencer
i'm like yeah
well compared to what i just did they're
probably like okay no she can't
i'm not an actor but hey you know i
resent that i'm boycotting
for you i am okay nope i'm cancelling
hbo you haven't even seen me
wait wait wait wait wait there's sponsor
sponsor i'm kidding i love hbo
yes they are i love hbo saying that i i
recant that as well as my daddy daddy
html.com 8th after dark i don't remember
that's is oh you're sponsoring not front
of me sponsor yeah they're mine i don't
care
but i do you come out here talking about
i'm kidding
um what's that clothes company
fashionable yeah [ __ ] fashion nova we
love them we stay on hbo up here
all right let's talk let's talk um
let me play for you just a little
something fun while you enjoy your
birthday cake thank you
you're welcome this girl made a theme
song for us that was pretty good
pretty cool okay here's a theme song by
uh what's her name it's so far away i
can't see it
it's uh caro
miller music cara miller music it's
miller time
that's the name of the wait what is this
what are we doing i have enough sound
who wrote you guys theme song because
you don't have one so this girl wrote
[Music]
oh
[Music]
wait so what do we do was that our theme
song what is happening nothing i just
wanted to play for you
she's so cute whenever you see people
that watch you are you always like
impressed there's like
like good looking people that want you
because like i always just like
like i'm always the ugliest in every
photo like i look like i am like the fan
in every photo i'm just like this dumpy
little thing
no i am impressed when like normal
people watch i'm like oh [ __ ] that
person watch
i guess that's what i mean i mean
everyone's good looking but okay the
next thing is i get credit for this
i understand that right wait why i was
the one that called you xena why'd you
share it you say that i knew you didn't
know who this was
you shared it you literally shared it
and said i want to be
i want to start in the remake hashtag
xena warrior princess you literally
don't even know who it is i'm the one
who said you like
xena warrior princess and now you're
sharing this memes i just want to say
that i
this is me i get the questions yeah
that's a compliment
she's so skinny i thought so too and
you're like oh i don't know who that is
and you still don't
i still don't but um moses found this
for me and i thought i looked really
pretty so i said save that give it to me
put it in tiktok format i'm posting it
it's from reddit right i don't know what
it's from i don't know
i never know who to give credit to i'm
like is this i just told you it's in
xena prince's warrior you did the
hashtag zena princess warrior
yeah he told me that on sunday okay okay
yeah i'm glad
um i love i love i love them dr drew was
trying to break us up again
oh yeah dr drew is the enemy of the show
no we love doctor i love dr jerome
i tweeted you a very nice birthday
message from my heart
um i said i'm honored privileged to call
trisha my friend
she's an amazing person full of wet
insight and grit i mean literally
lots of grit like sand and i'm just
kidding grit means like
you're you're strong she is without a
doubt made me a better person for
knowing her that's true actually
and happy birthday week besties so
you're like oh we're having such a good
uh connect we're having in a really good
place right yeah
dr drew be like i think you guys need my
help again
i'm sorry dr drew are you trying to
break us up like please
well i'm curious to know his advice i
kind of want to know what we need help
on maybe we do need help and we don't
know it oh someone had a funny comment
you remember the tarot card reading that
says someone's going to try to break us
up
dr [ __ ] drew swooping in trying to
cause problems he did hint at maybe
doing a podcast with me so if you dump
me or whatever i can go on to dr drew
did he say that to you when
i when he was on the show last i think
he said something like i was already
thinking this dude dr drew
is trying to break us up the tarot card
was about him i'm sure of it he just has
too many podcasts with too many people
anyways
i would just be like number nine on his
list i'd be like below adam carolla and
tom segura and all these people you know
i wouldn't do it i wouldn't leave you i
wouldn't even leave you for who's a big
fat
even hypothetically thinking through
this like well
i would probably be not his biggest
project uh
excuse me it's working he's already
breaking us up
no i go where i'm i'm a priority and i
feel like i'm somewhat of a priority
here
do you not see what we did for you i
know no today was an up day for sure
you're always the priority here thank
you
now eat this no no but we saw each other
like four times we've been seeing each
other
so much where i'm like oh my god are we
going to be like two we got to change
the besties we're no longer friendly
we're like besties because we just see
each other so much
i agree you know i like it i'm down with
it but
we have to fight more no
yeah for real so um
oh okay then there's this justine
paradise girl who
is getting so much harassment i just
want to do a quick update and support to
her
because she's like a racing or social
media because it's all the death threats
she's getting
this is a girl who accused jake paul and
keemstar
called her a liar publicly and this is
the result of basically keemstar calling
her a liar
from random people but people who are in
los angeles
telling me that they're here so i need
to watch my back
people saying that they will fight me if
they see me people saying that i need to
kill myself like there are so many
messages of people telling me just to
kill myself
and that's super overwhelming for me
because i've never
experienced this amount of hate on the
internet before
the hate is so insane
the things that people are making up
about it
it's so weird even seeing people's
podcasts everyone makes their own little
assumptions about the video because
it's only a 20 minute long video it's
not like hours of me
saying every little tiny detail so
everyone has their own little
assumptions about everything and it's so
strange to watch it's so
strange to watch so many people
judge even the tiniest things i say or
if i'm looking off to the side when i'm
talking which i do a lot
it's so weird to have this much
attention and especially for so much of
it to be
negative it's really hard i've been
considering just turning off all my
comments
and making my messages so only people i
follow can message me
and because at first i just kind of got
wrapped up in looking at the comments
because when people ask questions i
wanted to be able to
answer them and defend myself but
there's just so much
disgusting hate that it's just pointless
to even go through it
i know what happened so there's no point
in me
fighting for the internet to believe if
people don't believe me they don't
believe me it's like
that sucks a lot i put out my video
for a few reasons the first reason is i
wanted to protect other people
and spread awareness about it and i
definitely think i did that i can check
that bach and spread awareness about it
whether people believe me or not at
least now when girls hang out with them
they'll have that in the back of their
mind you know
the other reason is i didn't want to
keep that a secret anymore
i hate keeping secrets that it's so
awful so
holding on to that was so heavy
for me but i saw this tick tock right
before i posted the video this is
actually the thing that pushed me
well anyway she's getting a bunch of
[ __ ] from people like keemstar who are
calling her a liar
well you know what no yeah and like
words of advice for this kind of thing
it's like she was right she's like it
gets exhausting trying to defend
yourself like you shouldn't you
shouldn't just like put your tooth out
people are all like there's always
people that won't believe you like even
if it's like hardcore like there's
evidence out there of everything that
happened with me and like people still
be like i don't believe her
like one people will not believe you
guys like stop reading comments two
people like move on you share your truth
and the truth will either eventually
prevail look at me two years later
people are like well trisha was telling
the truth on some things whatever
um or you know what people just kind of
move on and forget about it but like as
long as you tell your truth and you do
what you need to do like if you want to
press charges don't press charges
whatever it heals your heart you know
like just do it but you just gotta like
not be online that's what i give those
people especially like during what it
gets like
last week i had a little bit of a
meltdown you know so i just got offline
for a couple days and honestly it was
i did get the vaccine which kind of made
me sick i know when i was like whatever
i got sick from the vaccine i mean i was
only one day but like it was nice to be
offline for that day
even though i was sick i was like oh
it's like a reset because the internet's
not real and the people who like tell
you
like those trolls are like not real
people they really are i have only
gotten one hater in real life
and it was like a nine-year-old david
doberg fan and he's like before he's
like nine
but other than that like i've never had
hater there you go i think that's good
advice yeah you gotta have to like just
share your truth and just expect that
half the people won't believe you but
that's who cares who cares i really
wanna
also just continue to dispel this myth
that people are coming forward for clout
like i'm sorry
yeah it looks like she's having a really
good time with all the clout she's
enjoying over there
but again those are like literally those
are like the young like kids or just
like in cells or just people who are not
smart like that think though nobody
thinks that if you're like intelligent
or you're like really young yourself if
you're like a 17 year old who thinks
like that's how you like get cloud or i
don't know what oh
speaking of keemstar i wanted to mention
this on the last episode but i forgot
my birthday week i don't want drama well
i just wanted to say not about you
you're you're innocent in this but for
everyone listening who
loves ila myself included who's that
angel keemstar
literally was tweeting pictures to her
and me
calling her a horse for like a year
because he was mad at me
literally sending pictures of horses to
me and ela saying that she looked like a
horse
that's like yeah that looks like can you
imagine me to you but it's like someone
like
who literally is like so not probably
like what's the point she's beautiful
amazing exactly and so like obviously it
didn't bother me but i was like
i cannot believe that this is a like
almost 40 year old man with a daughter
and he's sending
daily horse pictures to me and ela to
call her a horse
and then when a b started defending me
he started sending pictures of witches
to a b
and his wife lena saying that she looks
like a witch who's also a really
beautiful
amazing person i mean keemstar is the
worst part 25
000. but it's also like when you're like
so ugly on the inside like him i feel
like he's just ugly people he's tracks
ugly yeah he's just
yeah by association but whatever i hate
that i hate when general and guys just
like
make fun of people's like look for
whatever even like even if there's i
don't know it's always weird
it's so weird it just it was like and
people thought and like his fans thought
it was funny
and like a lot of people started
tweeting horses to ela and i was like
wow this
is crazy but also the fact that people
like are doing that with their like life
thinking it's going to like affect you
guys like it's just
no more so i was just like i can't
believe this is a real person
like it doesn't yeah no not at all it
never affects
me like any i mean because i'm like numb
to it but never [ __ ] me anymore when
people call me like something yeah
the looks it's like i mean we're all
we're all we should all be like
i mean look i and people aren't always
secure with their looks but like i mean
i mean either he looks beautiful she's
not gonna get offended from keemstar
calling her a horse you know
it's as weird so anyway there's that
week
okay okay he like makes flies up about
me and then like it's it's one of those
things where you just
it's so exhausting like that girl like
you can't defend yourself like people
are gonna believe what they want to
believe
and they're just like even if it's so
ridiculous but it's still like annoying
yeah keemstar
has spent he's he lies about everyone
you know what it is it's like i okay
here i want to say this too here's
another statement i want to make
like i if someone has like an issue with
me or anything i have no
problem like addressing it if it's
something i did wrong or something i did
that was bad like i will always address
like my bad behavior in the past now
currently whatever
but if something's just not even in
reality there's been a couple of people
this past week yeah
where they're just literally making it
up i'm just like uh that's when i start
getting like triggered because my own
head starts being like oh my god cause i
start getting that
um you start thinking things that are
just not true because they're putting it
in this like fake reality so if
something's just so far off reality like
i can't even address it because like
what capacity what mental capacity could
anyone have to like fight a lie like
that it's so scary when someone can just
make things up out of thin air and at
that point just gonna be like okay we'll
let the cr them look crazy i guess but
well you know
one of i'm not avoiding things if i'm
not talking about something it's really
just because like it's just lies and
there's
it's so hard to deal with people like
just flat out lying because it's like
how do you dispute it and two it's just
so disturbing that people are willing to
believe
something that like there's no evidence
for yeah i mean one of my
my hardest like year or two doing this
is when is
because of keemstar he started this
blatant lie
that i was did i talk about that i was
stealing video
money from a video game that was
supposed to donate to charity and um
he spread he started this lie and it
spread so much that people were making
videos about it and i was getting so
much hate and i was trying to ignore it
for so long and not talk about it
but it became this point where everybody
online just [ __ ] hated my guts
because of this lie he made
and so i finally made a video addressing
it i had the game developer on
he's like no that money was for you guys
it's not have anything to do with
charity that's a total [ __ ] lie
and it came to the point where i was
actually able to like exonerate myself
and some people's eyes by just finally
addressing it
but for so long it's like it's so
[ __ ] depressing to be hated for
something that you didn't even do
and it's like you don't want to address
the drama you don't want to deal with it
but it's like
someone like keemstar never stops he
never [ __ ] stopped but i think it's
like shown over time like i've always
been like really competitive and like
just with anybody else not just team
keemstar anywhere else
like over time you either show like oh
this person was telling the truth or
this person just has a habit of doing
this
and for so long i was that habit of like
being a troll or whatever and be like oh
so we have to like break it but
after a while i feel like people will
see it you know what i mean like i think
they see but it's good to defend
yourself if it's something serious and
you're getting a lot of hate like i
i would but then with my instance
sometimes people spread lies and people
like okay clearly this person is just
like making this up or whatever but
my problem is before i started lexapro i
got really really depressed from all
this and just being like hated by so
many people for this [ __ ] and like
i just felt like i wasn't in a good
space to even speak on my behalf like i
was just so
[ __ ] depressed and just in a horrible
mood all the time and just really sad
and so when i started medicating myself
and feeling better and then i started to
see things a little
clearer where i was like i i'm gonna
address this and i'm feeling like
confident
finally to be able to address this in a
good way internet's tough i mean i
i really do think it's tough when people
are like i get why people like leave
like jenna marbles you know what i mean
i think after a while you just get
exhausted
i think i'm just actually crazy where
i'm just like every morning i'm just
like here i go again you know what i
mean but like i
i think like a mental like stable person
would probably be like i can't do the
internet for too long
no i think a lot of people just they hit
a wall where they're like
i can't take this you know you know what
yeah
i've literally like been like the voices
in my head for so long they're worse
than the voices on the internet so like
i can take it you know what i mean like
i've been hearing like [ __ ] talking in
my head since i was like five years old
so i'm like oh this is like nothing
my own voices are like you're an idiot
or you're fat the internet is like
whatever
if i'm telling myself that does that
count as a voice
i don't know that's a good question i'm
like i'm fat i'm an idiot yeah mine are
like voices in my head
like actual yeah and i've had that for
like
my whole life but like not as severe but
you know
you have characters like names of people
no i don't i wish i did
people would probably have believed me
earlier on but like i don't have names
they're just random it's not like
reoccurring characters it just comes and
goes
yeah it's also just thoughts like i
think i told you too it's just like
thoughts where i just think like
i think of scenarios that aren't even
true in my head like like i was telling
you last you guys thinking like oh
you're getting tweets or something about
me so that means you're going to end the
show moses is going to leave me because
then
you guys aren't my friend family anymore
like you start thinking all these
thoughts that just come out of like
nowhere you know what i mean like
i don't know but i snap back into
reality i'm here yeah when i saw you
i saw you over the weekend you seemed
like really you were having a rough
time yeah it was a rough week it was my
freak but like honestly like like
i'm good now and you seem totally back
fine birthday
i'm fine now [ __ ] i get you
know what do you know the love language
things
i've heard of you know yours or no i
don't
my love language is hamburgers
food yeah feed me baby well there's a
love language called like gift giving
and i never do this as a thing and
that's literally because i love like
buying people things and i love getting
things like
to me that's like love you know but
that's a real love language i always
thought that was like shadows
i think i don't know what my love i
think my love language is literally just
language like i like telling people nice
things affirmations words of affirmation
yeah that's my love that's one so it's
like words of affirmation gift giving
um physical touch what are the other
ones
uh what are we talking about with like
significant others or people in general
i think it can be in general i think
it's a general thing like what what do
you feel loved and what do you do for
others to show love like do you do like
chores to show love that's what's duties
no duties that's
moses he'll like do everything and i
like love him so much like he'll do
everything i'm like whoa
what is that called there's quality time
but there's one that's like you're doing
stuff for people
i don't do duties i do language acts of
service acts of service that's what it
is
acts of service are you a service man
yeah but when we first met he wasn't it
was like really what we like fell in
love
right exactly now he's doing service
no but no i feel like no moses is a
different person like he's really like
in love with me now i can tell because
like he just does like
so your gifts your love language is
gifts so
what have you ever bought me
that's true and i probably bought you
other things like oh
oh i forgot the present what present
oh i bought you a present for my
birthday you bought me for your birthday
oh i know what it is oh love language
that's a love language oh no we'll give
it next week on friends because it's a
frenemies
kind of gift but it's so dope and it was
a custom thing that i hadn't made it for
six weeks it took
oh that is a love language oh no
because i had it like three weeks ago
i'm like i'm gonna say it for me maybe
the menorah the
the rhinestone monorail menorah that was
good but this is really
okay yeah i'm so mad now because now i'm
like wait no i did get you again and it
took six weeks to make
even motions like wow this is like a lot
of work that you put in wow
i'm excited okay well i have something
to look forward to i love like just
buying people things like i love like i
just like love it like when i got to eat
i love like paying for every like i just
love it it makes me so happy it's not
like to show off like even when i was
broke i just love paying for things like
i love i think it's so fun
gotta hang out with you more no i always
pay for things too i feel like i always
favorite for everything yeah i think but
that's like you know i'd say it's
because i like it even like moses
doesn't even like like gifts but i'm
always like trying to buy him like
sneakers at nike's like i just bring
himself he never wears them but i'm like
here's gifts
sometimes you wear them but someone
called his gift i got him shoes from
nike and someone's like moses is wearing
dad shoes and so he's never worn him
since
someone told that to me once and i was
like i can't ever i was wearing like
really bright nikes and [ __ ] and someone
was like oh you're wearing dad shoes
like
i'll never wear these shoes again and
i've been wearing sandals ever since
just kidding i love gen z thank you for
watching it wasn't a gen z it wasn't a
gen z person
yeah don't worry we love gen c i love
gen z
okay so there's a few other things jason
nash fifty dollars you wanna talk about
that it's pretty funny
jason nash was hiring people for
uh the jason nash show for a full days
of work and offering them 50 bucks
less than minimum wage this is so basic
i was under the impression that jason
nash
sort of went into hiding after ethan and
trisha
annihilated him but violated him
come on oh annihilate i was like
violated i was like highlighted himself
i'm ready to violate you uh why don't
you bend over for me jason come on oh
oh okay that was a good uh beetlejuice
reference
now say my name as if i let you in come
on three times all right
he apparently started a podcast this is
a casting notice for the jason nash
and he's only paying fifty dollars
i just think it's really interesting
that he's curating an entire new show
instead of
making an apology video preaching girl
okay um pre-check um
we preach also so it's a full 12-hour
day for 50 bucks i was like bro that
ain't even like [ __ ] minimum wage i
made a response to this when i
used to do extra work from 2006 to like
2010 and this was 2006 right so like
for six for eight hours you got 64. that
was non-union so that's like the minimum
they could pay you
yeah you have to pay minimum wage that's
that can't be that's got to be illegal i
mean you can't pay people
under minimum wage i mean bro you're not
like how i mean listen
he's been doing sponsored posts he's not
like he and he's been like
you know ha ha on people's comments he's
not like he's not he has no remorse he's
just thinking it's gonna blow over and
no way are we gonna let that happen as
soon as the jason national comes out
we're
like where's your apology let's start
with that
no but seriously wait what is he
apologizing for everyone
because he wasn't there to you or or
like
no i'm seth oh seth right i forgot it's
been so long now
there's been so much we've been through
he expects everyone ever yeah he
definitely requires
jeff what exactly everyone's like oh
david in the eye and which is it is a
huge thing i'm not saying that but like
people just they they just that's why
they wait it out they're like you know
what people will forget about it
but it's like i totally i'm sorry seth i
totally cause there's been sweeping
there's been so much happening i've
totally forgot about this set thing
there's so much with jason other stuff
that came out that was just beyond like
so we need an apology
and also you're gonna have to increase
that rate bro or we're calling
i think like minimum the set thing that
might to me is like the most vulgar
thing and that like the fact that like
they he never had to apologize like ever
dressed at one point like that's true
and jason's the perpetrator
and uh you know what watching like just
things here is like so triggering
because
david's there like you know yeah
whatever man whatever you need to do
when we jump on a plane i'll jump over
play but like with me i was just like
oh i don't know i'm so bitter by it i'll
say it i'm bitter i'm bitter as [ __ ]
like he just
people are just like patting david on
the back for doing like the bare minimum
and it like just drives me nuts and then
jeff's like
his thing was like oh jump out of a
plane risk your life and then everything
will be better it's like you're talking
about his document right yeah i didn't
watch the new part
that'd be like me saying like oh why
don't you like get shot in the leg
without a band without consent and be
strapped down to a gurney in the middle
of cedar cyanide that'll make me feel
better go to a mental hospital for three
days that'll make me feel better have
none of your friends check on you
that'll feel better have all your
closest people abandon you that'll make
you feel better
[ __ ] right there's [ __ ] and
jason doing the jason nash show he's a
loser anyways honestly i think that's
his punishment it's just being a loser
washed up i don't know 50 that's his
punishment you know what he he's getting
he's reaping what he sowed so that's
fine
i'm afraid that the um i'm not i haven't
watched he was part of jeff's
documentary but i'm afraid that it's
turning into like a david redemption
tour
yeah it's you know it is what it is
that's what it helps them heal okay cool
you know that's fine but
it is it's totally it's i mean i guess
it's it's up to jeff to forgive him if
he wants to i mean
it's not necessarily bad i mean all of
us can still judge david for like
being super irresponsible and putting
people in danger like and they and
people are perpetually
yeah people like it's fine it's jeff's
story and how he wants to forgive david
is his own
okay but did you see now like scott did
you see his apology
bro don't just pull that up dan or ian
whoever's back there
well because he turned it into like
self-promo and it was like made me want
to die
scotty sire you're talking about the
song yeah that's so scottie
and i folded into we scotty ourselves
put out a video defending david and
everyone's like wow this guy is a
[ __ ]
dumbass it's definitely when the
steamy's extra
definitely that's the dumbest moment of
anybody's career ever on youtube
people like that video what yeah that
was insane
he's like i i choose to be uh to be
beheaded for no reason that was so
weird well anyway but then every but
then in jeff's thing too he's like wow
seeing all my friends run to save my
life and then making them seem like they
were like heroes for once again doing
the bare minimum
like obviously they're gonna run and
they're gonna come to the hospital like
what like it's not they're not heroes
they're just not and also by the way
david has jumped from a plane twice
before this so don't act like this is
your first time david dobrik it's on
video
with liza koshy
yeah if this is gonna make you feel
better then also and also you're not
risking your life jumping from a plane i
mean come on yeah you want him to risk
his life going to trapeze without a net
or something
let's see that conveyor with how about
jeff gets on an excavator and
tosses your ass around like a rag doll
and then stops while going 60 miles per
hour and you slam your [ __ ] face into
hard metal
cold metal here's scotty sire he put out
this video
and i was like oh what at first i was
like okay cool and then at the end he's
like so i wrote a song and i was like
and i closed it real fast i was like no
not a song
no because i saw that noodles with this
and i was about to come underneath it
i'm like oh like this is nice
like someone's doing something right
well anyway the thing is he's like a
budding or but i won't say budding but
let's say he's uh
established rap star right that's what i
meant to say
triple platinum established rap star
here it is
a song within the last couple of months
because i was going through some [ __ ]
because
i made a huge mistake i [ __ ] up with a
video
i love how his girlfriend started to
comfort him too she touched his arm i
wanted to
discuss how i was feeling about the
situation that i was going through you
know like
i i made a mistake i i talked about
something that i thought that i knew
more about than i did
and also it's all about him right it's
not about like it'd be like i'm sorry to
the victim
i'm sorry sad yeah people don't know how
to apologize like there's
because he's still yeah he only regrets
talking about it
because he got so much hate yeah yeah
yeah yeah only his his
regret is only uh self-concerning
he doesn't care about what happened to
say he doesn't believe seth probably
yeah for sure you can never
you can never understand how someone
else is feeling
great so brave because you're not in
their head you can only understand how
you're feeling
in your head
so it it kind of after i mentioned let's
get those subs rolling in by the way
what is this on it's twitch let's get
those subs in please for a sad boy
it's okay baby doing great wait that was
my band don't don't associate that
well he's a sad boy okay you owning sad
boy now i have a trademark
you have a stray monkey yeah 7205 is
trademark not sad yeah 2005.
they're you're not the first sad boy the
sad boys have been around since the
beginning of time
adam adam was reported to have been the
first sad boy banished from the garden
adam who's adam you know rib of god
first man
abel was the first cyborg oh yeah i
don't know who that is adam got banished
that's pretty sad
fair enough abel got murdered so well
that's
dead we don't even know if they have
existed they might be fairy tales
i'm just saying if you go back there's
spin sad boys before you okay
wrong i was about it and how
eight days to go by the way on the
subway it was to trigger something
with the video that i made like i i was
i like put me in a very bad spot
because i was i was so what ashamed of
what i'm so having done
um and so i got a lot of comments that
were very negative
and death threats and oh my god the
death threats it's okay you know
negative comments about her right cause
you put her in every video she doesn't
have to be there you know that's true
it's like he's in every vlog
and she has her own channel people were
calling you really horrible names
because she was liking tweets defending
him including stuff about me so okay
it's okay babe profile
that made me feel like
i i like truly truly [ __ ] up
so why did you [ __ ] when i was
feeling at my lowest point
this is the song that i wrote no
no so the whole thing was just
culminating in this self promo of a song
he wrote which watching it back is
actually not as good as i thought when i
was watching i'm like you're right he is
just so self-absorbed like
i like oh i got so much hate and so many
people gave me negative comments it had
nothing to do with like actually
apologizing yeah nothing
you didn't even mention seth yeah oh
i actually hate that but now it leads to
this ultimate self promo of a song let's
listen to it
[Music]
including my own i people call my music
[ __ ] that i sing awful
fine you're allowed to say that so i'm
allowed to have an opinion
well you always say your music [ __ ] and
his voice is awful i don't think it's
voiceover but i agree
his lyric writing is truly [ __ ]
tremendous with peace and love
for him after this makes me gross i've
listened to some of his other music and
i was like
hey come on buddy just could do better
but like the thing with
people can i also say this in general
like hey i support anyone doing music if
you have the funds to make your own
music career
do it that's what i'm doing don't take
yourself so seriously he swears he is
just just eat this
the way that was positioned at me i just
like wanted to come on
come on you look hungry eat this sorry
i'm beetlejuice
go ahead anyways his music sucked don't
listen to it he said
he's a horrible person well hold on
let's see let's play all right
she's been through so much is he gonna
claim us he's not gonna claim [ __ ]
he has a song oh my god he has me being
the biggest scott sire fan i do watch i
do consume a lot of youtube doesn't mean
i'm feeling everybody
there's a song that he goes zoloft
prozac lexapro
all of these drugs that i've tried
before it's about just the
antidepressants that he's been on
that was like does it rhyme or he just
goes
it's like prozac dun dun lex a pro
all of these hold that up i want to hear
it i want to hear it but anyway let's
listen to the chorus of the song i can't
remember it but it was something like
that
[Music]
you know after i posted that video and
stop wait that's it
listen baby at all anyway i really made
this beautiful song
i think you guys can really like i have
zero respect for scott
if i was on tic tac my respect for scott
i would do one of those graphs down
right graph is trending down on respect
this is like
[Applause]
i am the victim in this situation
i hated that watching that back i was
like oh he's actually like like he he's
the lowest
yeah david jason then him do you want to
hear about the lexa pro song i take lex
bro full disclosure i love lex but i
don't know
this is why i don't like to talk you're
saying my life sucks no oh yeah this is
why i don't like talk about you're
talking about like my mental
health this past week but i don't like
to talk about it because i don't think
you should like necessarily glorify it
like normalizing it but you don't need
him like in this song you know what i
mean well he's definitely being like
these are my antidepressants
i like normalizing it and recognizing it
when i first
when i first started taking lexopro i
was so scared to take the first pill i
was like
this is i don't know where am i gonna be
able to still do comedy am i gonna steal
my show
am i gonna be different or also i felt
like i'm weak for taking this i can't
just figure this out on my own
and i was so much stress and anxiety
over like
i had those pills on my bedside for like
six months before i finally had such a
bad day where i was like i need to just
take this
and i'll tell you straight up those
lexapro like um
saved my life for sure talk about it
normalize it all that stuff like that
but anna nicole was very glorified so i
started taking like prescription drugs
same thing with prince he took a lot of
xanax and i was like you know what what
a way to go
if prince died so you know what i mean
so i don't like when people like sing
about this
this is my video let me hear it and i'll
tell you if i think he's glorified
okay i hate anti oh anti scotty scotty
club oh boy that's an answer you know
antisocial social club yeah they always
ripped off stuff they got
calvin klein like they did one called ck
for kerner cough and calvin klein like
actually caught like like you can't see
that it was the ck logos it's like you
can't
by the way with peace and love
anti-social social club's my least
favorite streetwear brand for the record
i like the way that i sound right
i've seen this graphic so many times
editing that's like the
preset title font that's the list of the
concerns i'm just saying
like bro you could do you think have
changed could make my voice
deep like one of those little wayne
trolls
no she won't stick her sticky fingers in
her purse
mommy won't put her stinky fingers in
her purse i hate that [ __ ]
mom's a [ __ ] [ __ ] i mean these are
catered bro bro
why you gotta be such a sim for david
why you gotta open the line with a like
[ __ ] dick suck for david dobrik merch
his whole channel is just david and the
vlogs but now that david's not an a he
gets like 80 000 views like their whole
thing was just
having david in the vlog can you just be
your own man why are you going to sing
about david dobrik i love how he's
turned into scott [ __ ] on scotty
he's the worst like honestly watching
that he's like a [ __ ] person like he
doesn't understand he doesn't grasp he's
not
he shouldn't be like he has something
wrong i feel myself
i'm so sad that i
got [ __ ] that looks like that sounds
like him i literally thought that was
his song i was like is that the song he
just sang
seth kind of had it coming
though god he's such an idiot from
church because i can't let anthony get
the merch first
my birthday is april 1st okay you keep
singing about david dobrik
celebrate cause last time i choked on a
piece of cake when
i turned eight mama said i was a mistake
it ain't really bothering me
okay internet trolls always calling me
weird i get
mad she thrown at
i'm not dabbing on my haters i'm just
hiding my tears
i do think you know what's going on okay
[Music]
wait wait he lives a good life and
pretends it blows
yeah he's like you know he grew up in
orange county he has like a life that
people would probably think of like
privileged or whatever
i do feel like he does he does have
mental issues so i don't i don't want to
i i i don't want to pile on him you know
what i mean because like i know how bad
that feels
okay but no i just had it bad oh no stop
i am so
sick of people using mental health as an
excuse to be like a [ __ ] person
or not know what's going on in the world
because i have a lot of mental health
problems and i know not to lie about
people not to be delusional
not to accuse people of stuff that they
didn't do not to say someone was an
essay or whatever the [ __ ] like not him
and other people this week
oh i have adhd i have this it's like get
it under control it's not other people's
problems like it may
explain your behavior or whatever and
i'm sure he has issues and i'm not
doubting that one bit
but to like use that because now it's
like now he's like oh no
but this is me i'm i'm i'm actually
having a hard time it's like because i
have this issue it's like no you're a
[ __ ] person own up to it
i understand why you should be
apologizing to seth and not doing a
video saying you had a [ __ ] hard time
and negative comments remember you
deserve more negative comments because
you still don't grasp what you did to
seth
and other victims that you offended
including your own audience
by saying oh they should be feeling this
way they reacted this way so it must
mean this it's like so
[ __ ] like [ __ ] off everybody using
that's why i didn't want to talk about
you like okay
i had a [ __ ] mental breakdown i was i
had a i had schizophrenia and medication
diagnosed me this week i'm not going to
be like
well that's why i've been like this over
the year no i was a [ __ ] person for so
many years i had it untreated i didn't
get help
and that's no one else's fault it can
explain behavior but it doesn't excuse
you being a [ __ ] person i'm so sick of
people being like
he has mental issues let's not pile up
on him if you do something [ __ ] has
nothing to do with you taking zoloft
lexapro whatever the [ __ ]
like you're a [ __ ] person okay apologize
to seth you dumb [ __ ]
i agree with that so stupid
my girlfriend's getting hit don't put
her in your video that you're
apologizing when i'm doing an apology
video moe's not staying next to me he
has nothing to do with it that she's in
the videos
people are going to hate on her that's
just a [ __ ] he's right if moses is there
with you being like it's okay babe
people oh i'm so sick of people using
their mental health as an excuse
everyone is [ __ ] mental illness
fair enough you're right that's a good
point i guess i was like i just
i feel i guess i just was having a
little empathy and you guess what you
put music on the internet people can
critique it people can say my music is
sick sometimes sometimes it is
and sometimes music's [ __ ] you can say
it [ __ ] get off the internet if you
can't take it i don't know what to say
[ __ ] i don't know you're right you're
right i was just i was trying to go
light on the poor guy
i hate to when people just like monetize
i know you got some heat for this with
teddy fresh and it's not like a bad
thing i'm not like mad about it but i
really do
of when you said the crippling anxiety
and everyone got picked teddy bear and
stuff like that
it's it's fine i mean like i said it's
an opinion thing it's totally fine if
you want to do that with your art if
that helps you whatever but for me
personally
glamorizing it was really detrimental to
me wanting to be like anna nicole like
marilyn monroe like knowing they took
pills that's when i started taking pills
i didn't need pills i was like oh but i
should take them if i'm going to die i
would like them in my system
regarding so yeah we did me personally
but
no you're right you know i didn't even
think about it i made a shirt for teddy
fresh it was my design
and it said it was like a teddy bear
smiling in the rain it said i have
crippling anxiety
and a lot of people got mad and i
honestly all of us thought none of us
thought about it so we're like
i got where they're coming from where
it's like glamorizing it you know
and so we donated all the money to i
think
but i get your new wave no but i was
like i didn't think about that so i got
the point so we we remade it too and
changed the words but we donated
for people i think that deal with it and
i i know you have like you talk about
anxiety so i'm not saying you don't but
i'm thinking like people who deal with
it like so much like sometimes just like
seeing people like profit off or making
it like light again if it helps you it's
fine but like some people like it can
really trigger and i think that's gonna
be no i get it
i think i i heard people saying it like
you know if you go to hop topic and you
see like oh depression's cute kind of
like
a thing it's like it's just like
triggering you know because it's not
cool it's not cute depression sucks
yeah but you can get through it and you
can get help and you can have a
normal life oh for sure that's that's
what i learned is like
my life went from like so [ __ ] up like
internally and emotionally to once i
started getting help
which i was so scared and apprehensive
and nervous to do at first the moment i
like took that step in and i started
getting therapy
and taking antidepressants it was like a
[ __ ]
180 bro professionally personally
everything in my life just turned around
so like that's
that's my message to people is like just
getting help is
is great i think even if you're like of
stable mind or you just feel like
overwhelmed at times like talking to
therapists even if you're stable
because it's just like this outside
source like that like just is there to
like listen it's just so good like it's
hard
so they understand like the mental
pitfalls that we find ourselves in
like repetitive thinking and like
sometimes it's
you're thinking about this but it's
about something else and they understand
the
yeah the kind of the mental uh and may
is mental health awareness month
actually
oh my
[Music]
epic what else have you tried
[Music]
does that guy say next time on the left
in the 17 year old david
i don't understand his lyric he says i
pretend that it blows it sounds like
he's
faking his depression says i live a good
life but i pretend that it blows
um yeah i think maybe just i don't know
i'm not i mean i'm sure
that's not what he means but it's yeah
maybe i i would take it as him like
having a privileged
life but he's still depressed which
everyone of course can if you're rich
whatever who cares but like everyone can
get depressed but
i think that's what he was saying i
don't know i get the wording i don't
know maybe we should interview him ask
him
scotty what the [ __ ] did you mean by
this genius lyric interpretation
anyway i'm really glad i'm really glad
that he uh
he he wrote a song about his his really
rough situation so shout out to scottie
sire
oh this is a really interesting dude
liza koshy
david's ex who by the way she admitted
on whitney comes podcast that they
didn't even ever have sex
did you see that oh they didn't even
have sex nope orgasm that's what she's
oh he never made her come right
okay sorry i mean she said she's never
had an orgasm so maybe they'd never had
sex so maybe she was you know
you know what i mean well regardless i
posted this photo of us together
being like yo this photo was taken 1.5
years ago blah blah blah is my best
friend yadda yadda
and this was during the david scandal
and guess who liked this [ __ ] photo
liza koshy
that's kind of a thing though i'm not
usually one to go through likes and
stuff
but i was like that is kind of a that is
kind of a
that's kind of a spicy thing isn't it um
yeah liza i i met liz i hung out there
quite a few times she's
really nice and sweet and i think um
yeah nothing but a nice thing to say
about liza as well yeah i can't there's
no
i met her no but i was just no i was
just saying it's interesting that she
liked this during the david [ __ ] maybe
it was an accident it's kind of like a
oh please i've accidentally liked photos
before
okay but thank you liza fan of the show
friend of the show
i'm blasting through these really quick
front of the show i'd love to have lies
on
be like okay so tell me about your all
about your sex life with david did he
jerk off did you [ __ ] other guys
did she retire she kind of retired too
she pulled a genius like bye
do they just make so much money they're
like by a piece i don't know i blow so
much money he's doing like nickelodeon
shows and [ __ ] now
okay that was a while i cannot stop
being impressed by
how [ __ ] dumb know about your best
friend james charles are you guys still
friends have you been here have you been
hanging out with them what's going on no
we haven't been hanging out as much
but we're still great friends like
despite i'm here from whatever he goes
through i mean
it's part of being a friend you know
right i hope
if something would happen like that with
me like if that would help you do that
for me if you hope that if you
[ __ ] hit up a bunch of underage
people that hit that he'll also be there
for you what's going on in your life
noah
i can't i believe these people yeah
that dude is a serial predator i love
james you know i'm just being here for
him
and it's like admitted proven like you
can't defend those people anymore also
that's just so funny i hope that if i
get exposed for being a predator he'll
also be there for me he's setting it up
he's like he knows in the future it will
happen
so he's like hey james i was here for
you listen
there's nothing wrong with it but noah
beck is 100 gay
he's not and you can't out him i don't
know anything well how am i outing him i
don't know anything
i think if he's gay you out at him why
he didn't tell me he's gay
he didn't try to [ __ ] it and we didn't
have sex i think he a more
term maybe he's just dumb i think that's
better
he's both he's so dumb god i was
watching him on a podcast thinking they
think they'd change the world with
tick-tock like with the high pals he
thinks they think they
did you see like addison ray saying how
much like talent and hard work it takes
to be like in a tick-tock type house
it's so embarrassing when i see these
[ __ ] boy tick tocks it's like too much
for me it's all like
wait no wait let me show you this one i
i guess i could set it to the group this
one i i just thought this morning i
wasn't going to show you i just was like
this is so crazy let me are you just
going to send it to me um how do i um
there was another james charles accuser
bro did you see this this is a
fresh james charles accuser from his
cancellation bed
watch this okay look at this
hello i am james this is new is this new
for sure i can't tell to be honest if
it's okay i thought maybe i said that
that's what he says when he sees himself
in the mirror he caught his own
i mean at least james is taking like a
break you know like at least like yeah
he had the dc to do i don't think this
is recent and if it is you need to just
delete snapchat
james charles just delete it off bro he
needs to delete his [ __ ]
he needs to go move to like tanzania or
something and just live in a hut in the
middle of a jungle
okay did you see these tweets by machine
gun kelly bro
i don't even know who machine gun kelly
is like what's he known for like i know
him but i don't know
he is a musician like what kind of a
scotty sire like a rapper
that's what i gather like he was a
rapper but funny enough he actually
kind of transitioned into emo in the
last couple years
he is kind of a scottish he is katie
that is scott fire right there
his music is but anyway he's dating
megan fox that's his time to face that's
enough that's not scottsdale
yeah but anyway this is his tweet from
what is it he goes i wish 13
14 50 year old girls weren't allowed to
be so hot
so i wouldn't feel so creepy when i look
at them i'm still 19.
bro tweeted that i was like bruh
13 brah everyone is thinking you say
13 bro
what you tweeted the [ __ ]
i i mean twitter is just hey even even
for beetlejuice that's a little
you know what i'm saying 13 it's a
little young for me
i um oh
sorry not my tourette's no that was a
james charles that was literally just a
cough
everything's tourette's no i go um this
cake is good tourette's
that's you you have tourette's though
yes i have tourette's
okay she another one said there's a
little 13 year old girl next to me going
crazy over my transformer tattoo
don't worry though y'all i won't pull
out r kelly i am a little worried
whoa okay so i got a facebook message
from a 14 year old now saying hey you're
sexy as [ __ ] i tapped that
bruh you gotta [ __ ] chill you know
what twitter
this they should everyone just follow
your lead and just do a delete oh
because they click like i deleted all my
old stuff
because you don't know what's in there
man you see [ __ ] you're like holy [ __ ] i
wrote
that uh it it can be bad like tweets
that get pulled like obviously
tweets are not well to be honest if you
go back to how people were talking just
in general
yeah back like in like 2010
you're like holy [ __ ] people were wild
in back then
yeah by the way everybody's keemstar has
combed through every single one of my
old tweets so it's not like
anything yeah i mean mine are out there
too it's just like but that's what i'm
saying that's what i'm saying and i'm
not trying to like
be gen z here but jensen's kind of
changing the world because now we're all
becoming politically correct we're
watching what we say we're you know what
they're right though like the [ __ ] well
there there's something to be said about
like pulling up like 10 year old tweets
and
then judging them against that now but i
would say that i'm a much more sensitive
and
aware of the things i say and i think
it's a good i actually do think
i think it's great i think it's great
like just in general i feel like young
girls are not like
for me like when i was like younger and
stuff like that like if people i don't
know the way people talked and stuff you
thought
one thing about it i like that now we're
not like you know just women for their
bodies and like that i liked it as a kid
i was like oh yeah howard stern like you
know all these people like dude
dude i listen to how i love her story
but when i listen to old episodes i was
like this guy i can't hear this
it's like way too creepy yeah but that i
remember the first i met hugh hefner
when i was 18 years old
and i remember how to [ __ ] you
up because it happened three times to me
and he grew up and the third time he
grouped me he was just like oh you
gained a little weight and i wasn't
invited back to the mansion after that
he told me i was on list like c
or whatever that [ __ ] means and then
i always wondered if he [ __ ] all those
girls
um yeah not me but i know that's what
happened
i don't think yeah oh my god but in my
head i thought oh i'm not like pretty
enough for that
and everyone thought it was cool like
all celebrities important people are
like let's go over to the rape house
that's what i thought it was cool i was
like i need to be his girlfriend like i
wanted to be a girlfriend so i love that
we watched the girls next door every
night so i like that are you gonna let
that old guy crawl on top of you and
like
yeah i mean that was like my dream for
sure i was so messed up i was like
here's uh machine gun coverage my first
celebrity crush was because right now
it's kendall jenner
damn it i've said that so many
[ __ ] times i hope that
i'm snagging that don't let me move to
la oof
are you finding her counting down the
days until she's 18
i'm not waiting till she's 18 i'll go
now oh i'm 23 dog like
i'm not like a creepy age like you know
what i'm saying i'm 23 bro she's 17
and she's like a celebrity like there's
no there is no limits right there
robert plant who was one of the greatest
lead singers ever
don't know his song for led zeppelin in
his mouth there's like paper they look
like chip clips
rose who was one of the biggest badasses
ever dated a girl that was 16 and wrote
a song on his first date this guy should
not have grabbed
the girl oh i think i don't care
why is he flexing kendall jenner is in
your bedroom i don't give a [ __ ] if what
her age is i'm down
let's go i'm 23 we're both celebrities
who cares about the law let's go
pretty wild [ __ ] oh god i don't know bro
he literally tweeted any 13 year olds
out there want to [ __ ] oh i don't know i
remember what his tweet said but
this birthday party turn a turn there's
a good turn all right
let's get to the trivia i'm ready how
much time we got dan
we got time we got so much time we got
so much trivia
sandler's clothes on jimmy kimmel i
don't know how to do that someone bought
clothes from him i
i i what was it sold out
we didn't find out about it until uh
like i guess it was
the day after don't don't worry we're
looking whoever bottom will
will eventually end up selling it to you
do you think he's do you think adam
sandler started selling them because
he's like oh this is a hot commodity in
my clothes so he's like i kind of think
you did that because why else would he
be selling his clothes it's just odd
i don't know okay let's play some trivia
trivia here let's do a cut we'll come
back with trivia
all right we are doing trivia i am up
one point
if you guys remember from the last
episode i slam dunked you on an adam
sandler question
for the lead 8-7 i was really sad about
it actually
but you went home a watch punk drunk
punk punk
punch drunk love and you didn't even you
better get it
that's what's the deal you're a fake
adam sandler fan
i really liked him in the role i really
did not get the movie
i guess those movies and i know i'm
gonna sound so stupid and so i know so
please educate me but like what's the
point of those movies like i'm being
genuine like what's the point
there's no plot there's a story you're
not a journey there was a plot
hmm right i haven't seen a while there's
a plot right
i don't think it's just adam sandler
being like ah
i'm adam sandler i think it's a movie
because the plot you you you
what's it what's the word perceived
conceived what's the word where you
trick someone
you deceive deceived you deceived me dan
with the summary
the last question was the movie where
adam sandler gets scanned by a phone sex
operator i'm like count me in this
sounds like a great movie i'm gonna
watch and that was just like maybe like
a little like a sub
storyline it wasn't like the plot of the
movie you thought it sounded more
interesting
yeah okay there was like one phone
section at the beginning and he gets
scammed like a few minutes
here what would you say is the point of
a movie like schindler's list
i haven't watched the full movie yet but
but are you so
we prefer so it's up to you
jack and jill would be the only kind of
film that would be
because it gives you escapism from
reality like jack and jill's funny
lighthearted you're not thinking about
anything you're focusing on oh my god
he's a man and a woman like you know
you're focusing on like those kind of
things this movie was like depressing
and
he has a lot of anger issues and his
family sucks and like you're like this
is sad i hate myself after watching this
i know a lot of movies are very sad i
mean maybe i'm just not like a drama
person i don't know
i'd be surprised though i thought your
whole life is drama i don't want drama
this week and you said that you're a
queen fan and you didn't even see the
queen movie
yeah because the queen i was like bro i
was like listen i love
queen i know i'm a big fan of queen i
don't need to go see ramy malek who
we've decided as an enemy of the show no
friend of mine
put on some big-ass teeth and pretend
like i'm from mercury
i was like i i don't there's so many
biopics it's like bro i
biopic is out i don't need to buy up
about mark zuckerberg
i don't need one about queen i don't
need one about abraham lincoln i don't
[ __ ] need nothing about nobody just
write me a goddamn movie jack and jill
that's all i want
i want fart jokes and racist jokes from
matt really
i really do like grammy milk we started
mr robot i never saw it and we started
it
and this is so weird because i've been
talking obviously i was getting funny
and stuff like that and he literally
said something in this like right away
he said something about being
schizophrenic i'm like oh my god me like
it was so weird i was like that's a
connection
so i love you beautiful mind with
russell crowe
no it's serious huh it's like kind of
sad well he also has schizophrenia
really but it's like it won best picture
of the year i it's such a good movie
i never watch like draw i i i never
watch well it's really inspiring
actually
for someone who he's has schizophrenia
and the ending is very
inspiring i should watch it because i
really don't know much about anything
but
bro that movie's so good beautiful mind
yeah beautiful right now
seriously uh i love that okay let's play
some trivia
what a weird [ __ ] we took a break too we
took like a tell like you know i always
feel like we take breaks like that's why
it's like
the energy not a bad way but energy like
changes different vibes but we're back
okay nonetheless okay i think to them
the vibes feel the same
okay yeah okay it looks like you're
wearing a sofa there's a song i like
i know i haven't i'm changing it i'm so
big and i'm staring at you like you're
wearing a chair
thank you you're welcome at least i
don't look
all right dan okay
so we're doing the same format where you
both answer right yes sir okay
eight seven this is the finale this is
you are thank you
this is this is like it though we don't
continue to the next episode right this
is it
and if i win you have to say my name
three times okay thanks babe
you don't like me doing beetlejuice i
kind of don't know how to act when
people are in character all the time
i like doing a gag you wanted me to
dress up i can't do the game i love it
but like i used to take improv classes
and i
i think people thought i was being an
[ __ ] because i'd be like i can't it's
so funny you should do an improv and
she's like
because it's so they're like okay trish
you're great now try a character that
does
isn't all like uh seized up it's so
cringy to me and
i respect people who do it for real but
to me i'm like it's so cringe when
people are like
i've got a red banana and you're
supposed to say like yeah i've never
done that i'm not interested we should
do it for the show we should do it
right now like michael scott no what we
don't know the michael scott where he's
like
he has a gun he always does the gun yeah
that one's
all right let's ask a question damn it
okay
okay what is the tallest mountain on
earth
um i feel like that might be a trick
question but i'm just gonna write one
i only know one mountain so that's what
i'm going with oh i wrote it really
little i don't know why
everest kilimanjaro it is it is everest
uh
you only know one mountain and it's
kilimanjaro yeah i thought for sure it'd
be everest
i never heard of mount everest you never
heard about it
no is it the president is it the one
with the president's on it
no that's rushmore that's like a small
i knew that when i couldn't think of the
name though mount everest the big that's
that's where all the crazy
hikers go and they depend yeah they die
all the time i i didn't know the name
but i
would you you want to go to everest for
a friend of mine's episode no you wanted
to kill me
i would lose breath right away one step
i'm like yeah the exigent the oxygen
gets all thin
yeah we would just well it'd be
interesting to see how high we get we
probably would make it like one
thousandth up and be like
we have to return i would die i would
literally die i think you want to kill
me well that's fun
i mean like it would be a fun episode
jeez
i want you to live forever okay
i want you to live forever thank you i
don't know i changed my mind i go back
and forth like me babe hey
listen i've been living forever too and
i look great okay
it's so weird when people do voices in
her ankles what can i do you made me
dress up no i'm sorry
i'm never gonna stop i love it i love i
really respect it i think that's so cool
when people can do it i can't
go ahead dan thank you all right
in the film big daddy
wow i don't know this big daddies wait
is that a
sandler thing big daddy big daddy
you set me up dan
so in that film who plays uh nazo
the delivery man um easy i have
literally no [ __ ] idea so i'm not
gonna write it no you're a fan
you hate him i've heard you like go on a
rant about him okay so i know who it is
[Laughter]
i know i'm helping you rob schneider
yeah i didn't even know
that you knew that right away you're
like yeah i hate rob schneider
i love you around him you know i heard
he's really not such a dude
he's so unfunny and such a douche and
his show he has this netflix show that
is like the worst thing
ever it's like curb your enthusiasm but
not funny at all no i i
watched one podcast before i met you and
it was the one where you were talking
about that show and like his
you know talking about his wife and
stuff on that i was just like you were
so spot
so it was so good watching find that
highlight yeah that's funny
yeah okay rob schneider i heard he was
like the worst and he's always playing
like
middle eastern men and he's like
filipino but he's always playing like
middle eastern
filipino he's filipino and hispanic i
believe oh for real
yeah i think you can fight with me on it
he's jewish he's jewish too so i think
he's like
all of it yeah i mean if it's if it's
adam sandler trivia i think 15
chance that it dances rob schneider they
always he's always playing like middle
eastern men who like eat animals he
always eats like goats and stuff and i'm
like i don't think that's like
doesn't he play like the little racist
characters in all of his films always
like in zohan he's
pakistani and in big daddy he's like
indian or something like he's always
like
and then wasn't even jack and jill as
the no that was someone else
i don't know who that guy was he was
awful that guy was even worse than rob
i'm eating the chimichangas
okay thank you ian his grandma's from
the philippines little rob schneider
trivia for you
in case you're wondering we'll do a
whole schneider section
on the next time we do trivia what's
give me some more rob schneider facts
his grandfather was an american his
grandfather was an american army private
rob schneiderlin wow
okay we respect that dude i look like
rob schneider
beetlejuice is like rob schneider yeah
totally yeah
except much funnier it's definitely much
funnier he could never
can you imagine rob schneider
beetlejuice that would be like a zero
percent on rotten tomato
go ahead dan thank you we're one and two
now uh the rob schneider
since you just said zero percent uh on
rotten tomatoes here's a
question about just that starring adam
sandler terry crews and taylor lautner
this film has a zero percent on rotten
tomatoes
wow adam sandler god dude he's made so
many moves
terry crews i know who that is i don't
know who the other guy is
oh okay what the [ __ ] did he make with
terry crews
it had zero percent you know what
zero percent go ahead what is it i don't
know
it's grown-ups oh no it's not wait that
that's what the cat
the guy the king of queens guy what
movie was it well the answer that's
written here is the ridiculous six
oh i wha oh like terry crews was in that
the river
taylor water wasn't grown ups though oh
so that's when i was saying i watched on
netflix and i was like blown away by how
bad it is yeah it was like the parody of
hateful late or something
so bad i'm always so confident
and uh zero percent can you read a
review
read the synopsis
it's just so bad his movie's stuck i i'm
not well you just admit to me that his
movies suck
i know i think i'm a fake wow even the
audience scores 34 on this one
read the synopsis because they're pretty
funny usually uh
it says every bit as lazily offensive as
its cast and concept would suggest
the ridiculous six is a standard couch
fair for adam sandler fanatics
and must avoid viewing for film
enthusiasts
must avoid yeah i want to watch it did
you see it
yeah no i watched it just out of morbid
curiosity is rob schneider in it
probably i don't remember he's in the
mall right yeah like he's
he's always got it i love that must
avoid viewing for movie crit
for film lovers
his character's name is probably like
something super racist and offensive
what's in the character uh his
character's name is roman
it's offensive to italians get rid of my
adam sandler phone case i'm a fake fan
these are the only movies i've seen with
that i'm saying
you just love zohan i think so yeah you
just love gohan we do just re-watch that
over and over you might be right
dude his films are so bad with peace and
love you know i love the guy his movies
suck peace and love
he's very successful though super super
successful you're really super rich as
if that
yeah i was about to say rich some of the
old ones are yeah
none of the old ones go watch happy
gilmart it sucks just as bad as all of
them
it's cool it's cool if you're 12. i'll
stand by that one go
back and watch it and tell me you like
that one i saw the wedding singer a few
years ago why didn't singers go i don't
think he wrote that well why didn't
singer he was just acting in that one
what he did not write the wedding singer
he just acted i don't think he writes
any of his movies i don't think he wrote
the really bad one he doesn't yes he
does he produces them
no he writes the really bad one we watch
the credits and never says written by
adam sandler
guaranteed you're right about wedding
singer he didn't write that yeah he
doesn't okay
happy gilmore he wrote no he didn't okay
ian look it up co-wrote
okay well yeah that's right but like
that might be one of the only movies
he's written
read his writing credits he in
fact check here filmography go ahead dan
look he his filmography has its own
[ __ ] page
uh take that stickers off your phone
right now it looks like he is
he has only written like a handful of
them from what i'm seeing
billy madison happy gilmore water boy
the best ones those are the worst those
are the big those are okay
okay so you just went from saying he
didn't write any of them too oh he wrote
all the best things
out of 50 60 100 movies however when
he's done
it out of all the movies he's done he's
only written a
relatively small percentage but it's
true oh stop how did this be
most of the iconic
happy birthday next question he didn't
he he never writes anything
of five movies at the beginning of his
career he's never written anything
you're right
all right that was two atoms in a row
let's let's get off that what uh what is
um
what is the name of the big volcano uh
near tokyo
what is with all these volcanoes
mountains oh i know this one
it's called uh i know this one i think
oh no i don't want any volcanoes i know
this one
i think it's mount fuji mount fuji
that's a mountain
it is a volcano and that is the correct
answer mount fu
g we took a break i got off my game you
know i was ready and now
hold on we we still have time because i
take a little break and now i think
about
things would you have known mount fuji
yeah yeah like a fuji camera exactly
damn it's okay we have time
i want you to win it's your birthday do
what you got no no no no do not give it
to me because
i no i will win on my own accord you're
not right okay so stop
playing like oh i'm just the sad girl
who can't win a trip yeah
i'm building up i'm gonna come for the
like big comeback okay
you better get you better get i'm ready
here we go
what is the store that adam sandler
finds the magic remote
what is the store that adam sandler
finds the magic remote in
in the film click oh man
click guess who has not seen that
dumpster fire of a film
i don't like click either i gotta maybe
not made a sailor fan anymore i don't
really like click either you're like
you come here and you like don't like
any of his movies but zohan
maybe you're right he's just you
obsessed well he was israeli and jew in
that movie so that's double
i think you're right because it was like
you got to see this i'm like yeah and
now i like love it
damn i like hubie i like cubies
halloween too my answer is rob schneider
is a douche
bed bath and beyond she got it right
wait he bought it at bed bath and
beyonce yeah christopher walken he's
like in the back
the [ __ ] yeah that's an ad that was an
ad
i bet you they paid him to be in that
that's the thing he always does
oh my god he has what was that one movie
he had like ad
after adam yeah adam
jack and jill oh jack and jill duncan he
had like dunkin donuts he had cruise
ships he had [ __ ] like it was like
pepto-bismol you remember they're always
drinking pepto-bismol i was like bro
what am i watching
yeah it's so bad right he totally does
they're like oh i better tell you he
drinks some pepto-bismol it's like not
even relevant to the plot
you're like okay that was his thing he's
like yeah he kept drinking it
i was like why why is this character
drinking pepto business
damn am i like not i'm not standing adam
sandler anymore
category ruined dude click was like
really like depressing and like i don't
know
i'm about to click the adam sandler tv
oh
there's an adam sandler movie that
triggered me really hardcore i watched
it as like an adult and it was like we
tried to watch it we stopped after 20
minutes like literally triggered me
i started spiraling it was anger
management i hadn't seen it in so long
with the jack nicholson you have him
literally just trying to trigger like
getting him to like be
mad like yeah just lighting him really
that sounds to me like you don't like
adam sandler
damn enlightenment moment
we're switching to jack black this is a
jack jackpot we stan i stand jeff's life
he's a he's a god i'm problematic king
and you look like
uh kung fu panda thank you everyone
since already so much cake it's like
[ __ ] it
and it is my birthday do you want oh we
always have this problem where
we can't order it we need to send
something then that kills the joy every
time
yeah i need to move i need to move i
can't order pizza here what am i doing
here
i'm down yeah you should i'm gonna speed
my dream home when i literally can't
even order when you move you just like
get a new house you never sell the other
one you just keep buying houses i like
your method of moving just buy it out
keep this one but you buy another one
this one's too
i'd have to sell this one i don't think
so you're bouge not that boosh
you're a boujee i'm telling you i can't
afford to keep this out
i'm telling you right now i don't know
anything about your financial status i'm
just saying
oh well i'll tell you right now not as
boozy as you think apparently
i spend all my money i'm gonna get that
broken for my birthday 190 000
yeah 200 000 yeah what is it made of
[ __ ] the pubes of uh
angel angels i think ostrich oh maybe
how do they kill ostriches for persons
maybe i shouldn't get it never mind i
shouldn't
well they might be they don't kill them
if they just feathers i don't know it's
not feathers
i don't know oh it's ostrich skin oh it
is
oh no maybe i won't wear it yeah i know
it's [ __ ] i might become a vegan i don't
know we'll see
well like for example like um wool is
humanely
um harvested because the sheep need to
be clipped you know what i mean it's a
zone so wall is good ugg is fine ugg
boots are fine
if they don't have leather yeah i don't
think they do i think it's the wool
inside
so wool is great i mean the sheep it's a
it's a beautiful relationship the sheep
they're hot you cut their hair you use
the wall i mean god bless the sheep you
know what i'm saying
we love this oh i got so sad thinking
about the ostriches yeah save the
australians
all right well you know a lot of myself
two hundred thousand dollars i'll buy
you a house
thank you down payment time thank you
girl
okay all right go ahead right yeah
respectful dan over there
wait do we get pizza oh something but
we're gonna tell you every time we get
pizza something terrible happens
yeah we don't want to participate not
only let's not test faith this week no
peace
it's a good week no testing fate this
week
yeah next week we get the domino
sponsorship where's that dominoes at i'm
working on it yeah
i'll die i'll die for that wow
yeah i was using figure i'll die in the
process of sponsoring them
dope from eating their poisonous food
now
go ahead then it is poison but we love
it it's good poison
they say the best poison is sweet you
know it's sweet going down
best or worst well you know what i'm
saying the most effective poison i see
oh right is the one you willingly take
gotcha quick all right uh from what tree
do acorns come from what kind of tree
let's test your
tree knowledge right now i don't like
geography like stuff like
geography this is not geography
we've been doing volcanoes mountains
trees i i don't know any trees oak
it's an oak tree are you seeing that
that's a weird question i don't know why
you said that
no i know it's an oak tree choke
how many are you at four ethan is eating
that four
24. oh you're like oh okay we continued
from last time
i'm way off i don't know what's
happening it's an oak you're an oak
you know aton in hebrew means like oak
tree doesn't it or strong tree or
something
eitan means strong like an
or it's like something related to a tree
strong
oh strong there you go of course i know
okay hebrew speaker that's the second
time you saw hebrew this episode you
said
[Laughter]
uh in waterboy uh
what's adam sandler's character's name
something super racist and offensive
i'm the water boy little jewely boy
he probably the oh little chewy incest
boy who lives in the shade
let me win this i don't know it you
don't know go so godspeed bobby boucher
oh baby shirts are cousins
i don't know something really crazy and
offensive it's adam sandler
bobby boucher i love that movie that's
so good
bobby boucher yeah nice writing adam
[Music]
i could write a better movie than adam i
like that he puts all his friends in his
movies
i'll be in yeah i would like it too if
they weren't all rob schneider i really
think i'm going to be in an adam sandler
movie this year i really do mark my
words i feel like i'm going to be on
hebrews halloween too they're like
filming that i feel like i'm going to be
i'm out i want that for you
that's crazy i've envisioned that you
act like it's already up
that's crazy that i'm going to be in the
i envision our conversations but i'm
really cool i'm not like a fan he's like
oh she's really funny
no you're gonna nail it and she's like
oh my god and then you know how you use
all of his friends
you're gonna be in that rotation you
mean every atom yeah i'll be the new
kevin james he dies
yeah totally amazing
and you'll be the character that like is
super embarrassing and i was always
pooping in the bathroom and then they go
oh who farted
literally that's a joke in jack and jill
right
we talked about this last time i know i
can't get over it okay go ahead
begging damn please what's the
uh name of yellowstone's most famous
geyser
the [ __ ] nature questions every
single thing is i don't know anything
about
nature read it again i don't even know
what that is yellowstone's most famous
glacier
no geyser geyser i don't even know what
you're sure i have no idea shoots the
like
hot water out you of all people should
know when geysers geyser
i've never heard that word in my life
i know what it is it's a
think it's old yeller or some [ __ ] i
don't know
gold yellow isn't that the dog geyser
what is it geezer you don't know no i
thought it was old yeller
it is not all yellow it is old faithful
oh
a nice little hole for me old yeller you
know been around the block
oh my god okay oh
james ready excuse me jesus not
tourette's go ahead dan
what pop star burned down her home gym
with candles i have no clue
are you kidding me trisha's favorite
already
okay was it britney spears
yeah i was on my gym last week um but
it's being repaired
wait is it really beardy spears oh i
just guessed i was like who would do
that
okay i was right well do you what do you
mean
i didn't really get it oh are you gonna
not
let him have it fine that's why i'm
going to smell him
you are such a savage my impression i
was like i did this no
i said you said it out loud and she
confirmed it and you're like oh cool
well i was going to write it down it was
my only guess
fine whatever just give it a try i can
still win i can still win such a
saboteur you're
you didn't really get rob schneider
either because i gave you that hand well
you gave me that
you're like here's the answer i said i'm
still gonna win i'm still gonna win yeah
we'll keep
keep keep uh what do you call it
dreaming no when you like visualize
something
keep visualizing manifestations okay
yeah start manifesting you winning
ah i see it okay i see it i
lied at the end of the tunnel go ahead
dan
what is the name of the main character
on the show mad men
oh you know that i never even watched
the show but i know it
this show looks horrible by the way i
don't know the answer don draper
that's right draper yeah yep what's the
guy's name john something
john hamm yep yeah i never liked the
show but i like that they put um
like a plus-sized girl in there the girl
with the big boobs i guess she's not
really plus
plus size well she had big boobs and a
bigger waist
okay more full figured and oh wait is
that christina hendricks yeah
do you know her i happen to know that
it's her birthday today
just a really weird coincidence i was i
was driving to work today and on the
radio they were like it's christina
hendrick's birthday you know about her
that's all i know that's literally all i
know showers oh i know that she's a
45 i think they said that's
really i swear to god you know i was
husband's uh works uh scheduled it came
on the
news this morning they like wish her a
happy birthday yeah hmm
her birthday oh she uses uh oh another
firm she uses
oh i know what she likes oh i know that
she's right it's for lunch yeah may 3rd
she's 45 oh 46. she just turned 46 i
guess great
that's just a weird coincidence anyways
moving on from that
uh soccer status
uh andy samberg starred as adam
sandler's estranged son
in this film described on wikipedia as
one of the worst films ever made
i love this movie i think i actually
know it
i think it's little nikki no oh [ __ ]
that's my boy
that's it that is correct oh that's what
it's called bro i'm like yeah i've like
blacked out that
described by wikipedia as one of the
worst films
ever made what's that wrong tomato uh
let's take a look
such an illustrious uh history as a
filmmaker
that's my boy it's it's one of those
movies where he talks like slow like
billy madison he's like
there's a 20 so like this is one of the
things where it's like how does
adam keep making these movies i guess
people just really people watch him
yeah he makes money it sounds good
that's my boy is really good i like that
one a lot
he's so funny in that movie uh you must
be catching up on me now because all
these
questions are i know i told you i had to
like layla okay maybe the
maybe the manifesting works what's the
score now ian
13 13 all right i'm stepping in you want
to come on the set if i do
if i film this movie this summer come on
the set yeah and then he'd be halloween
too
oh sure yeah yeah what's up oh you want
me just to observe you
and your prime just you your fantasies
always involved me being an extra
like an accessory to your your rocketing
career because i never had a friend
yeah i'll come on i'll come on your show
of course i will okay hold on my sets
adams and they'll be like excuse me
they'll be like excuse me uh do you have
permission to be here sir i'll be like
oh yeah i'm friends with trisha paytas
they'll be like
you're not on the list i'd put you on
the list and then you'll be like okay
let me call her and then you come out
and you're like
oh hey ethan look we're really busy uh
adam's kind of just
wanting a little quiet on set i'll be
like okay trisha i get it
i know i thought about that would i
bring someone on set with me or would i
go by myself because i want like quality
bonding time
like with him in the cast you know i
wanna yeah you were big-timing for sure
you would definitely big time but i need
to focus on like one person so i thought
this is my
maybe i wouldn't bring anybody because i
was like i'll bring my mom and moses you
everybody you know but then i'm like oh
maybe i just need to go by myself
yeah you need to bond with adam become
his befriend him so you're in every
movie ever
his wife's in every movie ever maybe i
should befriend her his wife is
in every movie she doesn't she's a big
part he'd be halloween jackie sandler
i don't know what she looks like what
does his wife look like beautiful pull
it up there he married like a model and
she converted for him
she's like stunner i'm so gel
i'm so happy for them actually i'm not
jealous i'm getting married myself to an
israeli real life so on
she's so pretty look at that ah i love
their wedding bottle weird she looks
jewish
she even converted her looks she's like
maybe i look jewish uh rabbi
he's like a little of this a little of
that we're gonna give you plastic
surgery to increase
the i think that's anti-semitic saying
you look jewish
don't please don't don't pretend to
educate me
i said that you'd be like oh yeah well
there's certain things you some people
can say there's some people i've learned
i've evolved
yeah you've evolved
into what i
[Music]
[Laughter]
then i'm going to put a photo of her on
screen we're both like um what's going
on with dan thank you
like you were tweeting something i was
like okay christine hendricks so yeah i
was looking at what's your hundreds
are we tied still we didn't even get to
the next we've been chit chatting okay
next question is died
all right i'm getting serious now yeah
um let's see
no nature [ __ ] no rocks or oceans or
rivers
yeah just adam's rob schneider and adam
stay on their questions i mean there's a
ton of adam sandler
do you want to just do adam sandler no
i'm going to lose i'm not going to get
it one question
i know you understand that's why i'm
throwing in the the rocks why so many
picture ones
i don't know it's something other than
adam sandler listen there's
because there's no english uh uh trivia
in here because last time
somebody got so embarrassed that we
decided not to do anything
it's trivia so mean you're such a
[ __ ]
uh she was asking why it's all science
you are
such a stop manipulator this manipulator
about that why are you why are you
getting so freaked out you're like
dan you're such a [ __ ] and last time
you're like people don't like when i
yell at dance i'm trying to stop you
before you yell
but dan is always undermining me in
these quizzes that's a different way
stop talking like that to me
i'm fine i'll help you because you're
like damn [ __ ] you weren't getting
i'm not
you're not helping me you're treating me
like a child
you're demean you're being demeaning no
you're not helping
you're making it worse meaning would be
different be like now what did we do
last time that's like demeaning i was
actually like trying to help you like
okay
you're not helping okay i'm done thank
you bob [ __ ]
anyways uh no adam sandler
okay uh how many uh how many harry
potter books are there in the main
series
i didn't do anything you made it seem
way worse yeah okay
yeah you should be scared of you not me
seven seven oh you both knew that yeah
easy
i read it all right i read about me too
not a flex everybody
i'm not
harry potter like a [ __ ] fifth grader
harry potter it's embarrassing
oh did you like how it ended i didn't i
loved it i
loved alan rickman so much like i loved
him in everything he's my favorite
i felt like the plot was so stupid like
how it all like he goes on this big
journey
and then all of a sudden he finds like
these three relics at the very end of
the book
it's like spoiler alert oh my god it's
been on for like 30 years oh my god i
actually didn't see the ending
you said you read all the books i didn't
read all the books i stopped at goblet
of fire the other ones were just like
way too much
i actually didn't what the [ __ ] i know i
know
snape dies but that's all i know oh my
god okay
does he die does harry potter die harry
potter dot he's
actually he's um essayed by voldemort
it's really violent
very surprising twist ending oh my god
and then harry has uh voldemort's baby
through black ops read it it's crazy
that's what i say
boulder more you want to dress up as him
that would be fun happy snape
i love professor snape i would love to
draw setbacks voldemort that'd be really
fun
sounds intense but i think would be dope
makeup though
ralph fiance do you think you have no uh
nose or something
yeah yeah you're probably seeing that
head yeah for the podcast you might
be hard to talk for a couple hours like
that ralph fine characters and i could
be
schindler you want to play schindler or
who's the villain in chandler's list i
don't know i don't remember he played
the villain
or something i don't know maybe i
shouldn't be that's another it's just a
dude in his food bro
let me know that's not cosplaying no
a prolific jew killer stop i don't want
to it's too late to take it back you
want to be
do you want to be goblers i want to be
i want to be a nazi killer there you go
like a bear jew in
queen tarantino's glorious bastards
that'd be me i dressed up as the beardy
one time look it up quentin tarantino
treat us
bare jew you are a bear jew thank you
minus the bear and you you're a bear
actually you know what i noticed you
have no hair on your feet that's
impressive you have like no hair on your
feet you're very hairless for
a man oh i have a lot of hair on my
chest really but i don't have hair on my
back or my feet
weird i know i noticed that i have a
nice feet it's not like you guys have
really hairy feet and hair
that you mentioned that oh god
you know i have some hair on my feet not
a lot yeah it's like very minimal like
some guys have like really hairy toes
hairy feet but i have a hairy like
like chest oh my gosh okay if i did that
it's not that bad i mean there's worse
for sure yeah no
it's weird because but you're not hairy
on your legs or your toes
right hmm interesting i wonder why i
don't know
ashkenazi yeah the ashkenazi yeah the uh
the the uh so far or yeah the sephardic
well moses isn't that hairy either yeah
he has none on his chest our back it's
weird and he's middle eastern
he's like a twonk he's uh yeah
i don't know he's a jewish swank yeah we
love a jewish we love a jewish trunk
i love that he's jewish i look at him
every time
that's not the best part about him it
just turns me on a lot
it's so weird so hot
i just love it you guys have a role play
like into the jewish thing
we did once but it was like too weird
what was this it wasn't
serious it was just like i told you
about it it was kind of weird no what
was it no tell me
it was like it was like a joke but like
it it was weird and then we stopped tell
me what was this
it was like the shower one like he was
in the shower
he was in the shower and then what what
was the fantasy
no i don't oh my god moses
yeah yeah he brewed through that too
that's whatever just move it
yeah whoa freaky
yeah i love yeah he does it's so fun he
read a passover book to me
you do dirty no he'll just be like he he
read a passover book and i'll
ah like i was just so
anyways wow
you pretend that you're moses biblical
wife right
oh what's her name we know her my dad
calls him her name all the time what is
it i forget
something weird my dad will always call
me this biblical name what is it
zepora or something my dad he's like oh
hello zeporah i was like why
because he's really biblical so okay dad
we love dab okay go ahead dan defeat
who said one small step for man
one giant leap for mankind
my god this is like
you know that right yeah
oh no trisha what'd you tell him
where are you getting lance stewart from
wait what did you wrote neil diamond
neil diamond i never read it
neil diamond armstrong i knew neil
armstrong i'm not giving that to you
because there's so many adam sandler
questions you're going to get
that's [ __ ] oh my god
neil armstrong i knew it i did know that
one [ __ ] my life
i love neil diamond though that's way
better did lance stewart say it at some
point
i don't know why because lance stewart
i'm sorry i'm not as equally as dumb
exactly it's not easy all right i'm
taking the point on that one
how many are we at 15 to 14.
ethan's up by one okay i'm ready i'm
ready ready all right
um
gail diamond
uh another big daddy question for you uh
adam becomes
the um trivia i'm ready i'm ready i'm
ready
adam uh becomes the unlikely foster
father of five-year-old julian
what nickname does julian choose for
himself
oh oh oh
i'm just guessing because this is all
done
i'm taking another guess out here oh we
we literally just watch this movie too
hold on
oh easy easy oh my god i'm so stupid i
was thinking like scuba steam for him
but
there's a little nikki everything's a
little nicky i don't know
is there a little nicky question on that
frankenstein it is frankenstein that's
correct
you made a frankenstein movie no oh my
god you're so
dumb i'm so dumb because i don't follow
his [ __ ] trashy films
do you have a little nicky one on there
can you put a little nikki so i can get
one right
not a little to get the answer what's
the name of the movie with the [ __ ]
little nikki in it someone called me out
of my hypocrisy
when i was um [ __ ] on little naws
for the devil song everyone's like okay
but you like little nicky which is
literally about him being right that's
true yeah i'm sorry i'm a hypocrite i do
admit that i i used to be critical at
times so
there you go ipod is a little nauseous
it's not that big of a deal it's or it's
not
fun yeah he [ __ ] the devil i mean
that's great
who hasn't i've taken a ride
right all right
we're tired again i knew this would
happen little nikki
what uh what um adam sandler film
we're all what adam sandler film feature
what adam sandler film featured
a character with breasts atop his head
breasts atop his head yep [ __ ]
you know that
yes of course coming home
[Laughter]
to throw you a bone ethan i don't
remember a little [ __ ] kevin dealing
with him
every answer why would you not because i
didn't remember kevin neal with titties
on his head
i did this tv show with uh kevin ellen
he was my mom's lawyer i was suing my
mom
and jamie kennedy was my lawyer and
kevin ellen was my mom's lawyer
no he did not but i was one degree away
from adam sandler
oh my god literally though this is like
75 percent adam sandler but go ahead
birthday
you're right you're right you're right
you're right go add more salad
it's because you had cake so is there
any let me tell is there any more little
nicky answers just so i know
there wasn't even that i literally made
that up i just made it up in the spot
based off of my memory of little names
we get a hat one where the answer is
happy or one and then one more
jack and jill i'm really good at jack
and jill
stop all right next question
here we go um i'm hot are you
disassociating it look kind of like
you're disassociating a little bit no
okay i'm just hot now i'm having fun why
is everyone worried about me
i'm just having fun and then it's like
whoa i was like dan you're sabotaging me
i'm just joking around
and the truth is like whoa dude i'm like
nothing happened
why you're making me feel like i'm
losing my mind
i'm fine it is hot you always have it so
hot here we walked in damn was my
reaction
over the top when i was like dance
sabotage it's normal right i mean it's
become normal here become no you don't
don't make it sound like i'm abusing you
what the [ __ ] is going on here
i think you're just warm i do it it is
hot it is hot oh the air just kicked on
there you go it is we walked into your
house and i was like
listen we're we're almost out of time
okay uh so who's in the lead
uh trisha right one okay so here we go
uh
time for five more adam sandler
questions all right we'll slam through
them in 2011 close my pen
in 2011 no this adam sandler film
was nominated for 12 razzie awards and
won
literally every single one including
worst actor worst actress worst director
screenplay
ensemble cast and worst picture amazing
setting the record for the most razzy
wins in a single year and it was in
2011.
oh it's like a netflix one i don't know
dude that's that is actually impressive
i will give
i will give adam sandler props for that
people who don't know what the razzies
is it's the like
bizarro academy awards where they give
him out for terrible right
it's like the invertible performance
oscars i'm trying to think of a movie
would be that bad i think i know the
mother laughing answer i know the answer
well we've talked about it pretty much
every adam sandler yeah nicki
oh is it no what'd you type sandy wexler
jack and jill it is jack and jill i knew
it was jack and jill that movie is
dog [ __ ] what that's not fact check ian
fact check that out
i'm a jack and jill expert i've studied
that film like it's the goddamn old
testament
but you love it low-key if you're
watching that much you love it well i
made it
i made like a two-part video on it back
in the day yeah yeah
i want to watch that i think so i'll go
watch it tonight that's fun
so and i like trashed it why what the
true word
are you okay i'm beetlejuice come on
that's not beetlejuice
come on okay listen i i i've got a high
threshold for pain and i i couldn't sit
through
so many turns this episode i forgot how
we started and now you reminded me it's
so crazy
listen i've been dead for a thousand
years and i'd rather stay in the grave
than watch a
jack and jill you know you know
you wanted to do a four-hour show could
you imagine if we're doing four hours
this doesn't have two hours
you're already like who says i want to
do four hours last week you're like oh
people said we should do four hours and
do
part one part oh yeah i'm out i'm
already out on that idea i was like bro
i don't know
yeah it seemed like a good idea at the
time but then when i thought about
actually sitting down for four hours
you know what it is when you get your
costume your hair makeup done you
already put so much of your time and
energy
it's been up since like you know nine
o'clock it's like yeah
it's a good point yeah but some days i
do feel like we could go on forever and
ever
like recently we've been like oh we got
to stop because we're out of time and i
thought you know maybe it would be fun
to
shoot like an extra episode but i don't
know
one day maybe one day monday oh but we
do have an idea for fun extra frenemies
content
what is that but you know what it is
that we're doing this week but i don't
know if i should say it or not no
yeah secrets there is something far
coming so listen maybe spin off
it's been upside down my clock for the
show says an hour
58 which means we're almost out of time
and it is a tie score
so should this be the decider we have
two more let's do rapid fire
rapid fire i mean who says it first who
says the quickest no just like
no bullshitting no goofing around no
complaining just boom boom boom boom
okay what song does drew barrymore sing
while painting in 50 first dates
no idea okay wouldn't it be nice that is
correct
okay next next uh during
which global conflict was pearl harbor
in
hawaii bombed
how many stripes are there on an
american flag
rapid fire let's go 13 13. that's right
what television show did rod sterling
create who is rod sterling twilight zone
okay i don't know
that is right i should love him he's
amazing uh
which artist made history in 2020 as the
youngest winner of
uh the grammy's four main categories
best what is it album
recording yadda yadda the other two
yeah both got it
what is uh
shawshank in the movie shawshank
redemption what is consumption
redemption what was the question
what is shawshank what is that referring
to in the title of the movie
it's a prison it is a prison that is
correct i just remember jim carrey going
shawshank redemption shawshank
redemption i love that movie that movie
is so good what movie is that you know
see
it's based on a stephen king oh
shawshank oh my god you haven't seen it
no i love taking movies it's like the
best
it's like people say it's one of the
best films like if you go to imdb movies
it's always like number one can we write
that down too shawshank
oh my god dude that movie is so
interesting just so you know
because you said you like stephen king
uh movies
it's not a horror movie though no it's
not a horror movie oh well these movies
aren't really they're kind of thrillers
right
well this is this one this one is
unlikely it's it's straightforward a
beautiful
[ __ ] film it's just a beautiful shirt
okay maybe i won't like it
uh do you have to watch it i'm gonna be
scared okay i'll watch it it's so
beautiful do you like forrest gump
because it's like a force gun oh you
don't know
that's another one like what's the point
of it what
how could you say that oh my pen my
panic attack it's
[Music]
in the uh music video for the queen
song i want to break free
uh what did freddie mercury do that
garnered the video a lot of attention
and controversy
i've got it tell me when you're ready
dressed that's correct
same two justin drag look at us look at
you trivia masters
you should dress up by sam we should
remember our friday mercury okay i'm in
yeah what is
longfellow deeds dream job in mr deeds
did you just ask what long fellow's
dream long
fellow demons um
writing hallmark cards that is the right
film is that from adam sandler's big
giant turd
big daddy oh is that from big daddy no
mr deeds oh yeah yeah
i get them confused sorry i didn't know
there was mr dudes okay let's go even
when you
went on a writer nuts oh that was good
why
do adam sandler and kevin james pretend
to be gay and marry each other in the
film i now pronounce you chuck and larry
why are they doing that um
i'm just taking a guess because i never
seen that dog should film for taxes
his wife died so he had uh mary to get
going back in the system
uh the answer written here is for
insurance purposes yeah because his wife
died and
that's why i was like that's in the
system what's this i mean
basically like his wife died he didn't
have it so he could get did you get that
that little i mean it sounds like she
knows that well i said for taxes
i said for taxes that's be that taxes
it's as accurate as hers you guys
decided
i'm not i'm not judging this okay no
points
next no points we could go to 205 205.
okay we're uh we're running out of
questions here go ahead
baby let's do it what what day
is uh the unofficial holiday star wars
day
happy today uh
it's not today it's like what put your
answer down wait i know
i'm thinking
really stupid
yeah i know what it is may 4th yeah and
i was saying that for the viewers
i was like wait why is it today it's the
viewers okay
okay you're smart you're smart oh you
got my head i was like wait what is
today
you're like may 3rd i was like if it's
today's may 4th then that's not it yeah
okay uh oh jesus christ uh
calculated what is the uh name of the
alternate dimension
in netflix's stranger things oh
um do we already did we asked that one
last week
no we didn't okay you ready
oh oh no sorry i'm changing it now i'm
changing now i know okay
ready upside down that's right
like under or upside down okay going toe
to toe here all right i
think i think this has to be the last
question no it's not follows me from
stranger things he said he loves me
okay i'm ready what's the score this is
the last one
watch it be some deep cut adam sandler
[ __ ] okay go ahead
i mean i was gonna grab it what was
rob's the smell of rob schneider's [ __ ]
and uh the worst film ever made by roger
ebert
adam sandler stinky turd go ahead dan
it's her birthday i want her to win all
right uh in which
adam sandler movie does bob barker make
a cameo oh well we both know that so we
have to go to tie breaker
because he said he was the villain yeah
happy gilman
okay one more time keep going keep going
name the quote name the movie that this
quote is from
i just want to make people silky smooth
i actually know that one i think no
oh i don't billy madison
come on
[Music]
to win on a zohan question too yeah
outfitting wow
[Music]
thank you this is great and i can't wait
we have so much fun planned i'm so
excited to spend your birthday with you
no we'll have a recap next week we've
got a lot we have a lot coming up so
excited yeah you have a lot coming up
you're very busy this week i got like a
bunch of makeup on you i didn't realize
where i trust your chin
i either i just didn't realize that oh
maybe it's the suit yeah yeah he's like
i don't remember touching
my face don't make it weird
all right guys we have to get out of
here quick because we are running high
on the time you guys know what it is
and before people complaining that we're
ruining the show by cutting off hey i
didn't make the rules bye
love you guys dan out
oh that's good
[Music]
so
you